All right.
What's up, y'all? As always, welcome to
another live stream. Thank you for being
here. Tonight is going to be a treat for
a number of reasons. First and foremost,
I'm not going to be the one presenting
for the most part. You're not going to
have to hear me as much. I'll chime in
periodically, but Anthony Rogers is
back. He was here last time discussing
uh 1844 in the investigative judgment
with me. This time he's going to be
teaching on old covenant versus uh new
covenant worship and why the Christian
church universally meets on the first
day over and against seventh day. Talked
about this a couple weeks ago if you
remember in response to Mark Finley. Uh
we also talked about this a bit with Dr.
Brandt Bosserman who's also going to be
back uh in a few months when an article
of his drops in the Westminster Journal.
Uh but if you remember Mark Finley and
his regurgitation of Ellen White
claiming that Sel uh Satan held a
diabolical board meeting in outer space
to figure out how to attack Seventh Day
Adventist and the Seventh Day Sabbath.
Um but a few weeks ago I actually heard
Anthony give a presentation on this
topic. Uh a little bit broader than just
the seventh day Sabbath. But it was so
good that I asked him if he would come
and share it with us on this channel and
our community to which he graciously
enough said yes. So hopefully you came
spiritually hungry because uh and if uh
hopefully you're not adhering to the
Adventist health message because Anthony
is going to be dishing out a lot of
spiritual meat on the subject. So with
that said, Anthony, thank you again for
being here, friend. I will chime in like
I said periodically, but for the time
being, the floor will be yours.
All right. Well, thank you so much.
So
I was asked to do this in light I guess
or especially because of the relevance
of this to the Sabbath which is
obviously
an important
part of the divide between Christians
and 7th day Adventists. Now, as was
mentioned, when I discussed this, I was
looking at the whole issue more broadly,
and I want to do that as well this time,
and I hope to beg your indulgence on
this because I know for many of you,
you're primarily interested in the
question of the Sabbath, but I really
think you need to see it in its broader
connection. And so, what I do on my
channel a lot is I I say a lot of
things. Some people, especially those
that straggle in after I've started and
been going for 10 minutes, uh, don't
understand exactly what I'm doing. But
I'm usually throwing a bunch of things
out there because my goal is to
eventually bring them all together and
show you how they all connect and relate
and then uh uh hopefully you get the
logic of of the whole overall point that
I'm making. So, with that briefly said,
I'm going to share my screen. Oh,
actually, okay. So, you're going to do
that for me.
Oh, and then I need to do this, I guess.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
I think I'm doing that right. All right.
So, the Sabbath question.
Now, before uh getting into some of the
slides, there's a bunch of things that I
want to say that aren't on these slides,
but
really when you approach the Bible, the
issue of the redemption that is going to
be wrought by Christ and the redemptive
realities that are going to result from
it are already in view from the very
beginning. It's not merely when we get
to the proto evangelium in Genesis 3:15
consequent upon upon man's fall. Recall
that uh that text is called the protoe
evangelium the first announcement of the
gospel because it's there that we have
the first I would say and others have
said throughout church history the first
express or explicit prediction regarding
the coming redeemer. That's the text
where it says, "Consequent upon man's
fall, I will put enmity between you,
Satan, and the woman, between your seed
and hers. He will crush your head and
you will bruise his heel." So that's
considered the first explicit messianic
prediction. And it is really that
prediction that's being unpacked in the
rest of the biblical record in one way
or another. But having said that, that's
the first explicit prediction regarding
the coming Messiah and what he would do.
It's it's not the same as to say it's
the first time that scriptur is already
anticipating this. For God, the fall
wasn't the occasion when he began to
scramble about thinking, "Oh, what am I
going to do to reclaim humanity and
restore things to their primitable
condition?" The fall was part and parcel
of the plan. It was something that God
himself had ordained requisite unto the
end of sending Christ into the world to
take upon himself our nature, join us to
himself and exalt us to a far greater
position than we would have had apart
from all of this happening. There's a
lot packed into that and that's not so
much my topic, but uh the fact that I'm
driving here that I I'm hoping you'll
catch is that redemption was in view
when God set out to create. When God
created the world, he already had in
view future redemption. And one of the
ways that we see that is in the opening
verses of Genesis.
In the first verse of Genesis, it says,
"In the beginning, God created the
heavens and the earth. And immediately
on the heels of that it says the spirit
of God was brooding or hovering over the
surface of the waters. There we have
mention of the spirit the the ruach
haesh right the spirit of God. Sometimes
Jews to avoid uh undesirable
implications of that will say this just
refers to a great breath. But uh the
proper translation is the spirit of God
and that's borne out by certain
observations that can be made of the GR
with respect to the grammar and other
intertexturally related things. But uh
the spirit of God is brooding over the
surface of the waters. And then we we
learn that through a series of
successive fiats, God forms the newly
created universe, the the world, so that
it might be a fit habitation for man. He
speaks, he causes the light to shine out
of the darkness. He causes the dry land
to emerge, right? The worth the world
was submerged in water, but he causes
the waters to recede and the dry ground
to emerge. And eventually after several
fiats he creates man, places him in a
garden paradise and it all takes off
from there. But what we see in these
first verses is very interesting because
uh we have numerous events that seem to
be if if you will a reversal of what God
had done at the beginning and a uh
repeat a reversal and a repeat. So, for
example, the flood in Genesis 6, we're
told that uh the wickedness of man had
increased upon the earth. And for that
reason, God decided to deluge the world
in a flood. In other words, he was
returning the world to its primal
condition when it was submerged in water
prior to those fiats that I mentioned by
which he made it a habitable world. He
reduced the world to its primal chaos.
And then he as it were started it over
again with Noah and his family. So Noah
debarks uh or disembarks, however you
say it, the ark uh in Genesis 9 after
God again causes the dry ground to
emerge. He causes the dry ground to
emerge and and Noah disembarks and
begins to repopulate the world. He's
given the same commandment that was
given to Adam in the beginning. is told
to increase and multiply and other
things that were stated to Adam are
repeated in his case. And by the way,
don't miss that in Genesis 6 when it
talks about causing the flood to come
upon the world, it it explicitly
mentions the spirit of God who it says
will not strive with man forever. So
again, you have a reference to the
spirit in this context of the world
being once again submerged in water. So
you have as it were a new creation.
Peter even refers to it as if it were a
a beginning of a new world. Right? So
the the newly established creation
uh is is here uh in view. Although we
know that it's not ultimately the new
creation, but it is an anticipation of
it. Just like Noah is not himself the
true Adam who was to come, the last
Adam, he is an anticipation of him. He
is a new Adam, but not the new Adam. So
you already have this sort of pattern
being developed in the Old Testament.
It's repeated over and over again. I'm
not going to give you all the occasions
of this. Hopefully though, one of the
things I always tell people when I teach
or when I preach is that your duty when
you hear somebody is to improve upon
what you've heard. The preacher can't
say everything and it's always your duty
to move beyond that through reading,
through meditation, through
memorization, uh those sorts of things.
And so by hearing these sorts of things,
you should have it in your mind that
you're going to improve upon it. You're
going to be alert as you're reading
through scripture looking for these
sorts of things. If if there's a pattern
in scripture that you notice it happens
twice, it happens three times, well then
your ear should be to the text listening
for the signs of this uh on other
occasions. Well, the climactic event
though in the Old Covenant that really
picks up on this motif is, of course,
the Exodus. That's the event where God
redeems a people for himself. He
constitutes them as it were, his new
creation. Remember what God did at the
time of the Exodus? Again, I' I've just
given you the creation account. I've
given you the the deluge, the the the
creation of a new world or the cleansing
of the old world and and making of it
new. You should now be hearing this
motif when we recall the Exodus. Recall
what God did at the Exodus. The Lord led
his people out of Egypt and he caused
the the river
before them so that they could cross
over on dry ground. And then he
established them ultimately in a new
land, the the uh the land of Canaan. Not
before, of course, they wandered in the
wilderness because of their rebellion,
their their hard heart and and having a
stiff neck. But here again, you see this
pattern being repeated. What this shows
is that the the old creation
when it proceeded from the hand of God
was of course good, but had fallen. It
had been subject to corruption and decay
along with man. Man was the federal head
of all things. And and so when man fell,
everything fell with him. Everything
became subject to bondage and decay. And
this brought forth the need for a new
creation, which was being anticipated in
these Old Testament events, but not
ultimately realized. These events are
anticipating it. They're not fulfilling
it. They're not actually bringing it to
pass. But they are in in as much as
they're uh uh down payments on it,
they're anticipating it. They're
pointing to it. They're they're showing
us something of what is in view, right?
But in the nature of the case, these
things are all going to fall short in
significant ways. We can't look to these
things and say this gives us a full
picture of the reality. They're they're
always going to fall short. I'm often
reminded of the when I think of this of
how some people will uh certain Jewish
people will say that if Jesus is the
fulfillment of Old Testament sacrifices
then one of the problems that this
creates is that under the old covenant
there was no provision. Now I'm not
necessarily agreeing with this but I
will use this for the sake of the
illustration but they'll say there's no
provision in the law for willful sin.
And so, uh, what do you do in this case
if Jesus is the the way of redemption?
If if, uh, he's the fulfillment of
things and yet the Old Testament
sacrifices that he fulfilled included no
provision for atonement in the case of
willful sin. Well, even if that were the
case, that the old covenant sacrifices
didn't have such a provision, it
wouldn't follow, if you're following the
logic here of what I'm pointing out, the
logic of escalation from type to
antitype, from promise to fulfillment,
from the anticipation to the reality
that embodies it.
It wouldn't follow that just because the
Old Testament sacrifices didn't mount up
to this, that therefore the sacrifice of
Christ doesn't. Right? The sacrifice of
Christ is what they're pointing to and
what they all fall short of. And so we
shouldn't expect the shadow to embody
everything that we have in the reality.
All right. So again, I'll remind you
that what I'm doing is I'm throwing out
a bunch of things that I'm eventually
going to tie together. So I hope that
you'll labor with me and not grow bored
and think, get to the Sabbath. You know,
how does this work in relation to the
Sabbath? Uh some people think I'm
long-winded and that may well be true,
but uh part of what I'm also doing is is
not only uh giving people a lot of
information that I'm hoping they'll see
how it ties together, but I'm also
trying to wear out those who have no
real patience for the word of God. On
the internet, it's hard not to cast your
pearls before swine because after all,
you can't determine who's going to
listen to you, who's going to watch the
episode. Well, one way to uh get rid of
those people that aren't interested is
to uh tire them out. Uh the unbelievers
don't have the stamina to often sit
through hours of of biblical
instruction. Okay. But with that said,
I want to look for a little while at all
sorts of things that we see in the
prophet Isaiah. Now, Isaiah is not the
only prophet who does this, but he's a
perfect example of what you find in the
prophets relative or relevant to all
that I'm talking about.
If you look at the book of Isaiah,
there's actually a great pneummonic for
what I'm going to talk about. the the
the basic uh if you were to break it
down, if you were to
uh give an outline of the book and you
were to look at its major divisions, all
scholars would agree if you pick up any
commentary that the two major divisions
of the book of Isaiah are 1-39
and then 40-6.
Now, this is a great pneummonic because
the Old Covenant has, at least in our
enumeration, as Protestants, Jews would
reckon the Old Testament numbering of
books to 22 or 24 because of how they
group or divide the books. They have the
same books that we have, but they they
don't separate them the same way we do.
So, for example, they have Samuel, not
first and 2 Samuel. It's one book for
them. They have first and second or they
have kings, we have first and 2 kings.
We split it into two books. We have 1
and 2 chronicles. They have chronicles.
We count the 12 minor prophets
separately. They count them as one
scroll. So they have 22 or 24 books in
their enumeration. But for us, they're
39. Well, the first half of Isaiah
consists of 39 chapters, most of which
are about doom and gloom. They're about
how God is or going or is going to
punish Israel for her rebellion. So
chapter after chapter, although there
are some rays of hope that shine
through, chapter after chapter
emphasizes the judgment that God is
going to uh measure out against Israel.
So you have, for example, the Assyrians
spoken of in Isaiah chapter 10 where it
speaks of Assyria as the rod of God's
anger, right? Isaiah 10, I love how it
begins. It says, "Woe to Assyria, the
rod of my anger." So on the one hand, it
refers to Assyria as God's rod of
discipline. This is God's instrument to
judge or punish his people. Just like a
father is told in the Proverbs,
especially to use a rod to discipline
his own children. Here is God the father
saying that he's going to discipline his
people, his children, his child, his son
Israel. And the rod that he's going to
use to do that is Assyria. But note how
it begins. It says, "Woe to Assyria, the
rod of my anger." So on the one hand, he
speaks of his sovereignty. Assyria is
his rod. He's using it. He's wielding
it. But Assyria is culpable in this.
Though God is sovereign in using
Assyria, God is going to punish them
because they are culpable. what they do,
they do in accordance with the sinful
desires of their own hearts. God is
using their wickedness to his own holy
ends. God is, Augustine once said, is
able to strike a straight blow with a
crooked stick. Well, here's God saying
he's going to use the crooked stick of
Assyria to strike a straight blow
against his people. That sort of thing
is what you see throughout the first 39
chapters of Isaiah. But then suddenly in
chapter 40 it takes a major turn and the
emphasis comes to be on a new thing that
God is going to do. God is going to
bring about a new exodus, a better
redemption. The very thing that was
being typified in the creation of the
world, the deluge under Noah, the exodus
from Egypt. All of this is anticipating
this grand event when God is going to
bring about redemption through the
Messiah through that promised seed that
was spoken of in
the proto evangelium Genesis 3:15. Now,
by the way, before I start quoting these
passages from Isaiah, I forgot to
mention that when God brought the people
out of Egypt, we actually have an echo
of the creation once again in
Deuteronomy 32 when it's reminding
Israel of what God had done. Deuteronomy
32 was a song of Moses. Don't miss this.
There were there were two songs in uh
the Torah that have special relevance to
the redemption of the people from Egypt.
The first is found in Exodus 15, right?
The song of Moses. When they came out of
Egypt, they sang a song. They they
praised the Lord, his glorious right
arm, for delivering them from Egypt. And
then in Deuteronomy 32, Moses instructs
the people to learn another song in
conjunction with that. This song was to
be a reminder to them of what God had
done in delivering them and would be a
witness against them in the latter days
when they would rebel against the Lord.
Well, in that song, God identifies
himself as the one who brought them out
of Egypt into the howling waste of a
wilderness. It uses the same language
used in Genesis 1:2 and 3 where it
speaks of the earth as formless and
void, a howling waste of a wilderness.
It's the same Hebrew expression there.
But it says in Deuteronomy 32 that God
brooded over his people like an eagle
does over its nest. Again, you should be
hearing Genesis 1 when the spirit of God
was brooding over the newly formed
creation. Here's God saying he's
brooding over his newly redeemed people.
So when Isaiah picks up on this Exodus
motif, you're supposed to hear all of
this. This is what was already being
anticipated in the creation of the
world, in the deluge and the uh rescue
of Noah and his family
and in the Exodus from Egypt. Notice how
Isaiah 40 begins. Remember after doom
and gloom in the first 39 chapters. Oh
comfort or comfort, oh comfort my
people, says your God. Speak kindly to
Jerusalem and call out to her that her
warfare has ended, that her iniquity has
been removed, that she has received of
the Lord's hand double for all her sins.
So here the prophet begins this section
announcing that Israel's chastisement is
over. Now something different is
happening. It says, "A voice is calling,
clear the way for the Lord in the
wilderness." Now, the syntax here could
be rendered differently. There's
arguments over this. Some say that the
voice is calling in the wilderness.
Others begin the quote differently and
say that uh well, as it's found here in
the NAS, he the voice is saying, "Clear
the way in the wilderness." So it could
either be a voice is calling in the
wilderness, clear the way for the Lord,
make smooth in the desert a highway for
our God. Or it uh uh it it begins as it
says here. Uh I don't know if I made
that clear. The the point is you could
begin the quote differently depending on
how you understand the grammar. But uh
nevertheless, here you have a prophecy
of a voice
who's crying out saying, "Make straight
the way of the Lord." Right? Make smooth
in the desert a highway for our God.
Now, what you're supposed to understand
when you hear this is that this is the
New Exodus. This is what Isaiah is
talking about. The very phrase that he
uses here of a voice crying in the
wilderness would have struck every
Israelite eard drum in this very way.
The very
uh phrase that's used at the beginning
of the book of numbers when Israel is in
the wilderness. Remember they're brought
out of Egypt in the book of Exodus. The
book of Leviticus is really sort of a
uh a pause on the narrative. you have
some narratival uh instruction or uh
accounts there, but it's really a pause
in the narrative that is resumed in the
book of numbers. And so it's not as if
you've got this long time between the
events of Exodus and the events of
Numbers. Rather, uh there's this this
pause to talk about the institution of
the temple system, the priesthood, the
sacrifices, and then the narratives
resumed in the book of Numbers. So the
book of numbers is really uh part and
parcel of the whole Exodus saga that
that we're being given uh in starting in
the book of Exodus. So it begins saying
ba midbar in the wilderness. So when
Isaiah begins in this way and he says
clear the way for the Lord in the
wilderness, he's announcing a new
exodus. He's saying that a new exodus is
upon us. A voice is calling clear the
way for the Lord. Now this text everyone
should recognize. If you don't recognize
it, then you've probably not read any of
the gospels or all four of them or you
haven't paid much attention or you've
got a short memory uh or something else
even worse because this text is cited in
every single gospel. This is why it's so
striking to me when I hear people just
the other day I heard Bartman saying
that the gospels do not present a
uniform witness with respect to the
deity of Christ. He argued that the
Gospel of John teaches that Jesus is
somewhat divine. How's that for the
understatement of the century really of
of all history? But uh in his mind, John
was written last and Mark was written
first and Mark doesn't have anything
like this. Neither do Matthew and Luke
even though they give us a more upgraded
version of Jesus according to man. I I
think it not ironic or strange that his
name is man. I know the spelling's not
right there, but it should be e r. But
anyways, man said this and I'm thinking
right out of the shoot, Mark begins his
gospel by citing this. In fact, think
about this. It'll be relevant in a
moment. Mark's gospel the incipit says
this the beginning of the gospel notice
the beginning of the gospel
to yuangelu right to yu
the beginning of the gospel of Jesus
Christ the son of God just as it is
written in Isaiah the prophet and then
he proceeds to quote this text from Isa
Isaiah 40 together with it's a composite
citation together with Malachi 3:1 and
Exodus 23:20.
Okay, so it's a composite citation that
includes the book of Exodus, this
passage from Isaiah and Malachi 3:1. So
you have a a verse from the Exodus and
two passages from the prophets talking
about a new Exodus. Right? So this is
what Mark tells you his gospel is all
about. This is what Isaiah is talking
about as he begins this new section. But
notice what it goes on to say in Isaiah.
It says, "A voice says, "Call out." Then
he answered, "What shall I call out? All
flesh is grass. All its loveliness is
like the flower of the field. The grass
withers. The flower fades when the
breath of the Lord blows upon it. Surely
the people are grass. The grass withers,
the flower fades, but the word of our
God stands forever." Now, part of the
point that's being made here is that all
people of themselves in Adam are fallen
and corruptible. We are mortal. We will
fade away. Only those who have the
implanted word, only those who are born
again of the incorruptible word of God
will live forever. Right? That's the
point that Peter makes. Those who are in
Christ, those in whom the word of God is
dwelling by the spirit, right? Those are
the ones who will live forever. These
are God's new creations.
But it goes on, get yourself up on a
high mountain, O Zion, bearer of good
news. Remember I told you that Mark was
citing Isaiah 40 when he began his
gospel saying the beginning of the
gospel, right? The beginning of the
gospel of Jesus Christ, the son of God.
the very term that he used. He's not
picking up from the pagan culture as so
many are often inclined to say that this
word comes from uh pagan associations.
So for example, it's used to announce
the birth of an emperor uh and that sort
of thing. No, this is something that
he's picking up from Isaiah. This is the
good news. It's the same term when the
Hebrew was translated into Greek. When
the Hebrew term basar was translated by
the Jews centuries before the coming of
Christ into Greek in the septagent the
word that they used was yuangelon. It's
the word for gospel. Here Isaiah is
referring to this message of the Lord
coming in in the wilderness
as a declaration of good news. Get
yourself up on a high mountain, O Zion,
bearer of good news. Lift up your voice
mightily, oh Jer Jerusalem, bearer of
good news. Lift it up. Do not fear. Say
to the cities of Judah, here is your
God. Behold, the Lord God will come with
might, with his arm ruling for him.
Don't miss that allimportant phrase, his
arm ruling for him. Is this arm of the
Lord merely a idiom referring to God's
power? I would suggest to you even now
that it is far more than that. Even a
personification or a full-blown
hypostasis or way of referring to the
son of God himself, which I hope to get
to, but it goes on to say, "Like a
shepherd, he will tend his flock. In his
arm, he will gather the lambs and carry
them in his bosom. He will gently lead
the nursing use." So, here is the
opening of this New Exodus section in
Isaiah. Now, I want you to notice
several things in this section from
40-66
where you have this contrast between old
and new.
In
Isaiah 41, it says, "Thus says the
Lord." Note the Exodus language. It's
picking up this language from the Exodus
because again, we're we're talking about
the New Exodus. So, it's borrowing the
terms and language that's already
established in prior revelation for
this. Thus says the Lord, who makes a
way through the sea and a path through
the mighty waters, who brings forth the
chariot and the horse, the army and the
mighty man. They will lie down together
and not rise again. They have been
quenched and extinguished like a wick.
Do not call to mind the former things or
ponder the things of the past. What is
it that the prophet is talking about
here? Again, you've got to follow the
flow of what Isaiah is doing. Isaiah is
declaring a new exodus. When Isaiah
refers to the former things, he's
referring to the original exodus from
Egypt. That was the foundational event
that constituted Israel as God's
redeemed people. Right? That was the
event by which God brought them into a
covenant relationship with them when he
realized for them and with them the
promises that were made to the
patriarchs, at least tentatively,
initially prior to their ultimate
fulfillment in the Lord Jesus Christ.
the exodus was for them the foundational
event. That's what Isaiah is referring
to when he speaks of the former things.
When he says here, "Do not call to mind
the former things or ponder the things
of the past." And then goes on to say,
"Behold, I'll do something new." What
he's saying is this new Exodus is going
to put this old Exodus into the shade.
This new Exodus is going to be far more
grand, far more glorious. It's going to
put the the former Exodus out of gear.
It's no longer going to be that which
Israel looks to. It's no longer going to
be that which the people of God direct
their focus to when they think of that
event that establishes them as God's
people. That's not going to be the event
for them. That event will, as I said, uh
be moved into the shade. It says,
"Behold, I will do something new now. It
will spring forth. Will you not be aware
of it? I will even make a way in the
wilderness, rivers in the desert. By the
way, this language too is significant.
It's not only Exodus language and
therefore new Exodus because it's
talking about something new. It's a new
way in the wilderness. But the very word
that's used here is a term that's used
repeatedly in Mark's gospel. Mark
repeatedly talks about Jesus leading
them on the way, right? the the whole uh
complex of events that Jesus is doing
and orchestrating as he makes his way to
Jerusalem is uh a fulfillment of what
Isaiah was talking about. Elsewhere,
Isaiah talks about uh the the the person
that we're going to look at in a moment
in Isaiah uh leading the blind along the
way, leading the lame along the way.
That's exactly what Jesus did as he made
his way to Jerusalem to accomplish his
new exodus. By the way, uh for those
that don't know, in Luke, uh when it
talks about the transfiguration, when it
mentions Elijah and Moses appearing to
Jesus, it tells us, as the other gospels
don't, it tells us what they were
talking to Jesus about. They were
talking to him about his coming
departure in Jerusalem. The word for
departure in Greek is exodus. So, they
were talking to Jesus about his upcoming
exodus. When Jesus drank of the cup of
the divine wrath, when he was baptized,
as he says in Mark 10, he refers to it
as his coming baptism, right? When Jesus
was baptized on the cross, I know we're
not used to thinking of it that way, but
remember the Exodus from Egypt was
described as a baptism, right? 1
Corinthians 10, Paul says they were all
baptized in the cloud and in the sea,
right? as they came out of Egypt. Well,
that was an event for which which for
the people of Egypt was their
destruction, but for the people of God
was their salvation. Just like the flood
was destruction for the wicked, but
salvation for the righteous. Well, in
the cross of Christ, we have the true
Exodus where Jesus is enduring wrath for
his people, but making a way for us, not
into a uh earthly paradise, but
ultimately uh leading us to heaven
itself and into the eternal rest of God.
But uh the point is that the the gospels
describe this as Jesus leading his
people along the way. That's what Isaiah
is talking about. He says, 'The beasts
of the field will glorify me, the
jackles and the ostriches because I have
given waters in the wilderness and
rivers in the desert to give drink to my
chosen people. The people who I formed
whom I formed for myself will declare my
praise. Now, by the way,
the language that's being used here is
is something that some people trip up
on. They read this in a flat way, in a
wooden way. They don't understand the
prophetic idiom. When Isaiah talks here
of God providing waters in the
wilderness and rivers in the desert,
it's not appropriate as some Jews would
say, for example, Toia Singer, Michael
Scobach, these other anti- messianic
rabbis will often say, Jesus couldn't
have fulfilled these things because
after all, there weren't waters in the
wilderness. There weren't rivers in the
desert. But according to the idiom of
the prophet himself, which I'll show you
later, this is not a way of referring to
literal waters being created in the
wilderness, but to something far
greater, right? That if if that's all
that Jesus came to do, it wouldn't be
anything that much greater than the
Exodus. But what the prophets are
envisioning is something far greater,
something that outstris the original
Exodus, something that brings about an
entirely better state of affairs that
reorders everything, that changes
everything, transforms everything. What
they're talking about here, what he's
talking about, Isaiah, is the outpouring
of the spirit. All right? But I'll come
back to that. It goes on, notice what it
says. We're still reading Isaiah 41.
Thus says the Lord, the King of Israel,
and his Redeemer, the Lord of Hosts, I
am the first and I am the last. There's
no God besides me who is like me. Let
him proclaim and declare it. Yes, let
him recount it to me in order from the
time that I established the ancient
nation. So, it points back to that
fateful event, the Exodus, and let them
declare to them the things that are
coming and the events that are going to
take place. Now, one of the things that
the Lord does in this context where he's
talking about replacing the old Exodus,
the former things, putting it out of
gear, rendering it obsolete, and
announcing the the new Exodus, is he
challenges, he throws down the gauntlet
and challenges the false gods that his
people have gone a whoring after.
Remember the people of Israel, the
reason that they were langoring under
God's heavy hand of chastisement
according to the first 39 chapters is
because they had turned aside to idols.
They were worshiping idols, worshiping
God in illicit ways, and they were
forsaking his commandments and so forth.
That's why they were being punished. So
here God in this section where he
declares the new thing that he's going
to do is also at the same time
challenging the idols. He's challenging
the idols. tell us anything like I have
told my people. I declared those things
in the past and they happened. Now I'm
declaring new things. The Lord tells
them, "Let your idols do similarly. Let
them declare it. Let them bring it to
pass." In other words, if they do, then
they didn't they vindicate themselves.
If they don't, they prove that they're
worthless deities. They're they're
vanities, right? They are, as the author
of Ecclesiastes says, vanity. In fact,
uh the the the prophets often, it's a
shame our translations don't put things
as literally as they could, but they
often use the term when when referring
to idols, calling them wind and vanity.
It's the same uh term that's used by the
author of Cohellet, the book of
Ecclesiastes. But here, notice it says
that he established the ancient nations,
and he's calling upon their lifeless
idols to declare to them the things that
are coming and the events that are going
to take place. Do not tremble and do not
be afraid. Have I not long since
announced it to you and declared it and
you are my witnesses. Is there any god
besides me or is there any other rock? I
know of none. So here the Lord is saying
this is one of the ways by which he
demonstrates his divinity. The true God
is known by his ability to declare the
future and bring it to pass. Any god who
is not capable of speaking with respect
to the future so is ignorant of the
future say the god of open theism the
god of various cults the Jehovah's
witnesses others uh maybe um uh I don't
know what Ellen White taught about god's
knowledge but I imagine there's some
shortcomings there I wouldn't be
surprised
absolutely it's actually interesting
because uh the term open theism got
built upon further from its initial
inceptions by a seventh adventist
Richard Rice.
Oh, okay. So, I didn't realize he was a
Seven Day Adventist or I at least forgot
about that.
Yep.
Very interesting.
Yeah. So, it's still it's it's
surprising
that their movement would be founded
upon the puditive revelations of a
prophet while at the same time uh
calling into question God's absolute
fornowledge. But in any case, the true
God according to Isaiah
knows the future. He is sovereign over
it. He speaks with respect to it and he
even brings it to pass. Okay? So this is
an identifying mark of the true God. Any
God who cannot similarly speak with
respect to the future and bring it to
pass isn't the true God. But again, this
is all part of the context of God
saying, "There were former things that I
had done," meaning the Exodus, that's
going to be forgotten. that's going to
uh pass away. And that's going to pass
away precisely because of this new thing
that I'm going to do, this greater thing
that I'm going to accomplish.
Well, one thing too, just to kind of uh
point out something else about that
previous text, because I love that's
Isaiah 44:204, right?
Yeah.
Um and I love that you have more Exodus
imagery there with the with with the
rock. um that Jesus was that rock 1
Corinthians 10:4 that was with them in
the Exodus, that spiritual rock.
Yeah. Yeah. So, interestingly, in
Deuteronomy 32, I said that's another
song of Moses.
And it's in that song that the term rock
is repeatedly used for God. That's where
it's originally uh used as a as a title
for God. He's referred to as their rock.
He it says, "How can they perish unless
their rock forsakes them?" Right? So
repeatedly in that context, God is
called their rock. And remember, it's
rehearsing the events of the Exodus,
saying this is the event by which I
became your God. Not that I became God,
but became your God. Right? So I I took
you to myself as as uh your God and you
became my people. And so later in 1
Corinthians 10, as you as you're saying,
Jesus is identified as that rock,
right? So yeah, uh perfect stuff. It all
it all uh you know, coheres, right? This
is all new Exodus stuff. So, moving on.
Again, it says in Isaiah, this is Isaiah
45. Thus says the Lord who created the
heavens. He's the God who formed the
earth and made it. He established it and
did not create it a waste place, but
formed it to be inhabited. I am the
Lord. There's none else. I have not
spoken in secret in some dark land. I
did not say to the offspring of Jacob,
"Seek me in a waste place." Notice this
is the creation language at the original
creation. It speaks of the earth being
formless and void. God uh uh re uh
through a series of fiats, he made it a
habitable world. Uh I mentioned this in
connection with the creation as well as
in connection with the flood and in
connection with the exodus from Egypt.
Well, here is this language again. I am
the Lord, there's none else. I've not
spoken in secret in some dark land. I
did not say to the offspring of Jacob,
seek me in a waste place. I the Lord
speak righteousness, declaring things
that are upright. Gather yourselves and
come. Draw near together, you fugitives
of the nations. They have no knowledge,
who carry about their wooden idol, and
pray to a god who cannot save. Declare
and set forth your case. Indeed, let
them consult together. Who has announced
this from of old, who has long since
declared it? Is it not I, the Lord? And
there is no other God besides me, a
righteous God and a Savior. There is
none except me. Turn to me and be saved,
all the ends of the earth, for I am God
and there is no other. I have sworn by
myself. The word has gone forth from my
mouth in righteousness and will not turn
back. That to me every knee will bow,
every tongue will swear allegiance. They
will say of me, only in the Lord are
righteousness and strength. Men will
come to him and all who were angry at
him will be put to shame. In the Lord
all the offspring of Israel will be
justified and will glory. So notice once
again, you have this contrast between
old and new, between what God did in the
past and what he's going to do in the
future. You have this idea associated
with God proving himself to be the true
God, the savior of his people and
showing that the gods that they were
worshiping in uh deriggation of him are
not the true gods. Right? So
uh his old covenant people I I'm hoping
you guys don't treat anything that I'm
saying here as irrelevant to the points
that I'm going to make relevant to the
Sabbath and new covenant worship. All
everything that I'm saying is relevant.
Now, I may forget to tie certain things
together that my goal is to tie
everything together, but I I do again
want to remind you of what I said at the
beginning. I I throw a lot of things out
there. The goal is to bring them
together, but we need to understand a
lot of this stuff, have it in view
before we can do that. Okay. So, uh here
is Isaiah 46. Remember this and be
assured. Recall it to mind, you
transgressors. Remember the former
things long past. Okay. Again,
contextually, the old Exodus, that's
what he's referring to as the former
things. Remember the former things long
past. For I am God and there is no
other. I am God and there is no one like
me. Declaring the end from the beginning
and from ancient times, things which
have not been done, saying, "My purpose
will be established, and I will
accomplish all my good pleasure." Notice
here, this underscores the point that I
was making that not only does God
declare the future, but he's sovereign
over it. He he refers to this future
eventuation, these things that are going
to happen as my purpose. He says, "My
purpose will be established. I will
accomplish all my good pleasure."
Calling a bird of prey from the east,
the man of my purpose from a far
country. Truly, I have spoken. Truly, I
will bring it to pass. I have planned
it. Surely, I will do it. So again, we
have the contrast between the former
things, things to come, old and new. God
declaring it in advance. Uh the people
uh that he's declaring it to are being
called away from their idolatry and into
this new situation that he's talking
about. Listen to me, you stubborn-minded
who are far from righteousness. I will
bring near my righteousness. It is not
far off, and my salvation will not
delay. And I will grant salvation in
Zion and my glory for Israel. All right.
So, I think you're getting the point
there. There's more of that sort of
thing in Isaiah.
I'm going to skip over
uh some other references to that. If
you're interested, uh read Isaiah 48.
You have a particularly uh dense section
in Isaiah 48 talking about the same
sorts of things. But here's another
thing that comes up in this section of
Isaiah 40-66. Throughout this section,
we are introduced to a figure that may
appropriately be dubbed a new Moses. And
in conjunction with what this new Moses
will do, it speaks of a new song. Right?
Remember when the people of God came out
of Egypt, they sang a song of
redemption. They sang a song in response
to what God had done under Moses. Okay?
Now, one of the titles that's used for
Moses, in fact, it's used for Moses so
many times in the Old Testament that
when even when you use the phrase the
servant of the Lord, the the person that
most ought to come to your mind is
Moses. But Moses recognized that he did
not bring to finality the purpose of
God. He realized that he was but a
forerunner of that figure. That's why
Moses in Deuteronomy 18 said, "The Lord
your God will raise up for you a prophet
like me from among your brethren. You
are to listen to him." This is a
technicus termin because by the way,
it's a uh
it's a way of saying that uh throughout
the Old Testament, God refers to his
voice as that which his people are to
listen to. Well, here's Moses in
Deuteronomy 18 saying, "You have to
listen to this one." Which, by the way,
reminds us of Exodus 23, which says that
God was going to send his Malik, his
messenger, my messenger, Malaki, ahead
of you who will prepare your way, right?
And then it says, "Listen to him, for he
will not forgive your or pardon your
transgressions. My name is in him." So
this one has the prerogative to withhold
forgiveness and punish people for their
rebellion because this one bears the
very name of God. Okay. So Moses says
they're to listen to this one. He uses
the same language to refer to the coming
new prophet that will be like him in the
future. Like him in the sense that Moses
is a type and a shadow of that one. But
in the nature of the case, if this one's
coming after Moses, if Moses is pointing
forward to him, you're not supposed to
think of this one as on the same level
as Moses. Rather, there's an escalation
that is intended here. You're to think
of this one as greater than Moses, as is
the case in all of the foreshadowings of
the prophets. Every person who
foreshadows the coming one is
foreshadowing a figure and his work that
will be far greater than anybody that
came before them and and any work that
had come before him. So uh Moses
anticipates a new Moses. He is the
servant of the Lord par excellence in
the Old Testament. The only person that
is also called the servant of the Lord
that comes somewhat close to Moses and
even then Moses still uh goes well
beyond him is David. And both of these
are clear types of the coming one, clear
types of the Lord Jesus. But notice what
it says. This is Isaiah 42. So it's in
the New Exodus section. In this section
where God is talking about taking his
people through the wilderness again and
bringing about for them a better
redemption, putting out of gear the old
the old redemption, bringing about
something new. He says, "Behold my
servant whom I uphold, my chosen one in
whom my soul delights. I have put my
spirit upon him. He will bring forth
justice or righteousness as the Hebrew
word bears out to the nations. He will
not cry out or raise his voice, nor will
he make his voice heard in the street. A
bruised reed he will not break, and a
dimly burning wick he will not
extinguish. He will faithfully bring
forth justice. He will not be
disheartened or crushed until he has
established justice or righteousness in
the earth, and the coastlands will wait
expectantly for his law. Notice, they're
waiting for his law. this figure, this
servant, this new Moses is going to come
and with him is going to come a law that
the nations are waiting for. Okay? Not
that they in their hearts are aware of
this or in their minds think of this,
but rather this is the hope of the
world. And so, this one is going to come
and uh what they had not heard, they're
going to hear and they're going to
believe. What they had not been told in
advance like Israel as the prophet said
elsewhere, uh they will hear and
believe. So this new exodus, this new
thing God is going to do, this great
change, this great transformation is
going to be brought about by this coming
servant. It goes on to say, "Thus says
God, the Lord, who created the heavens
and stretched them out, who spread out
the earth and its offspring, who gives
breath to the people on it and spirit to
those who walk in it. I am the Lord. I
have called you in righteousness. I will
also hold you by the hand and watch over
you. and I will appoint you, this
servant, as a covenant to the people, as
a light to the nations. So, this one is
going to be not only for Israel, but for
the Gentiles, the He's going to
be for the nations. He's going, verse 7,
to open blind eyes, to bring out
prisoners from the dungeons and those
who dwell in darkness from the prison.
Right? This is the same figure I
mentioned that well, doom and gloom
marks Isaiah 1-39. And there's
nevertheless some rays of hope that
shines through. Well, in Isaiah 9, one
of those rays of hopes that shines
through is that prediction that the land
of Zebulun and Nahali would see a great
light upon them. A light would dawn and
then it launches into that great
prophecy of the coming son, the skion,
the the the king that descends from
David, who is the mighty God, and so
forth. That one would come and establish
justice and righteousness and so forth.
Here he's being referred to as the
servant. He'll bring the prisoners from
the dungeon and those who dwell in
darkness from the prison. I am the Lord,
that is my name. I will not give my
glory to another, nor my praise to
graven images. Behold, notice the
connection of this. Behold, the former
things have come to pass. Now I declare
new things. Before they spring forth, I
proclaim them to you. So the new things
that God is talking about throughout
Isaiah 40-66 are connected with this
figure. Okay? He's going to bring about
the new things. He's going to be the one
who puts the old things into the shade.
He's going to be the one that renders
that all obsolete, right? He's going to
one that He's going to be the one that
brings about this glorious
transformation that Isaiah and the other
prophets have in view. But notice what
it says immediately after this. Sing to
the Lord a new song.
Right? Because this is a new Exodus.
Because this is the new Moses, the true
Moses, the true servant of the Lord,
and because he's going to bring about a
new Exodus, a better redemption. We're
told that it comes with a new song.
That's why you shouldn't be surprised or
even scratching your head about the
meaning of those passages in the book of
Revelation when it refers to the people
of God singing a new song. Look at
Revelation chapter 5. Revelation 14. It
talks about the redeemed of the Lord in
connection with the triumph of the lamb
singing a new song, right? In fact, it
says they sing the song of Moses and the
lamb. Now, the the work of God in the
original Exodus has been brought to
completion in the lamb of God who takes
away the sin of the world. And so, they
sing not merely the original Exodus
song, but now the new song because of
what the Lord Jesus Christ will do here
in Isaiah referred to as the servant of
the Lord. So again, I hope you're seeing
the connection of this new Exodus, new
redemption. Elsewhere, the prophets
refer to this as a new covenant. They
talk about a glorious transformation.
They talk about a new song being put
into the mouths of God's people. They
talk about a law coming with him. He
will bring his law. Right? All of these
things are being spoken of in Isaiah.
It goes on. This is uh Isaiah 49 talking
about the servant again. Listen to me, O
islands, and pay attention you peoples
from afar. The Lord called me from the
womb. From the body of my mother, he
named me. Remember that at the time of
our Lord's conception, the angel
announced his name. You're to name him
Jesus. Yeshua, which means Yhovah saves,
right? Yeshua. You're to name him
Jehovah saves. to use the colloquial
expression Jehovah saves because he will
save his people from their sin. So he
was named from the womb of his mother.
From the body of my mother he named me.
He has made my mouth like a sharp sword.
In the shadow of his hand he has
concealed me. And he has also made me a
select arrow. He has hidden me in his
quiver. He said to me, "You are my
servant Israel, in whom I will show my
glory." Now before you think that
because he's named Israel, he is
therefore
to be understood as a reference, this is
to be understood as a reference to the
nation, which is the way many anti-
messianic Jews would read this. This is
the way Muslims hankering after
anti-Msianic Jews and liberals and so
forth will try and understand this. The
prophet will go on to disambiguous
disambiguate this. While it is true that
Israel is called God's servant, Israel
is a failed servant. This requires a
true servant, a new servant, somebody
who will recapitulate all that Israel
was called to do but failed to do. This
person will recapitulate all of that.
He'll retrace Israel's steps, atone for
her missteps, and bring about salvation.
This person is being called Israel. He's
the true Israel, the embodiment of
everything that the prophet spoke of,
the everything that the nation was
called to be. this one will actually
embody. He's called my servant Israel.
It goes on to say, "In him I will show
my glory, but I said, this is the
servant speaking, I have toiled in vain.
I have spent my strength for nothing in
vanity." So, it sounds as if this
servant is
on the verge of failure. It looks as if
his mission is failing to be
accomplished. I've toiled in vain. I
spent my strength for nothing in vanity.
Yet, notice the note of hope. Surely the
justice, the righteousness due to me is
with the Lord, and my reward with my
God. And now, says the Lord, who formed
me from the womb to be his servant, to
bring back Jacob to him, so that Israel
might be gathered to him. Notice, he's
called Israel, but not because this is
the nation, because notice verse five,
this servant called Israel will bring
back Jacob to him. Another term for
Israel. so that Israel might be gathered
to him. So this servant Israel is coming
to save Jacob or Israel the nation for I
am honored in the sight of the Lord and
my God is my strength. He says it is too
small a thing for you or that you should
be my servant to raise up the tribes of
Jacob and to restore the preserved ones
of Israel. I will also make you a light
for the nations so that my salvation may
reach to the end of the earth. So this
one is going to again bring salvation to
the Gentiles. This new thing that's
going to be done includes the the spread
of the sal the saving grace of God to
the nations. Thus says the Lord, verse
7, the redeemer of Israel and its holy
one to the despised one. To the one
abhored by the nation. Notice he's
despised and abhored by the nation even
though he is their savior
to the servant of rulers. Kings will see
and arise. Princes will also bow down
because the Lord who is faithful, the
holy one of Israel who has chosen you.
So this servant will bring about a new
covenant, a better redemption. He's
going to put a new song in the mouths of
his people. He's going to bring about
salvation. It's going to extend even to
the Gentiles. He's going to bring his
law, right? All these glorious things
the prophets talk about all of this is
anticipated in the creation of the world
in the redemption of Noah and his family
uh typically and in the redemption from
Egypt. All of this is pointing forward
to this far greater Exodus this far
greater redemption all brought about by
this servant of the Lord.
Isaiah 50 talking about the same servant
says, "Thus says the Lord, where is the
certificate of divorce by which I have
sent your mother away? Or to whom of my
creditors did I sell you? Behold, you
were sold for your iniquities and for
your transgressions your mother was sent
away." Why was there, notice this, why
was there no man when I came? When I
called, why was there none to answer? He
means, why was there no one who was
righteous such that he could interpose
himself between me and this sinful
people? interpose himself between me and
the people and turn aside my wrath.
That's the idea. Why was there no man
when I came? When I called, why was
there no none to answer? Is my hand so
short that it cannot ransom? Or have I
no power to deliver? Behold, I dry up
the sea with my rebuke. I make the
rivers a wilderness. The their fish
stink for lack of water and die of
thirst. I clothe the heavens with
blackness and make sackcloth their
covering. Now all of this is leading up
to something in Isaiah 50 uh in Isaiah
50. But I do want to make one point
before moving to that. Here he talks
about clothing the heavens with
blackness and making sackloth their
covering. This language is judgment
language. It's used throughout the
prophets. But significantly
a a specific way that it's used is in
connection with the death of the
Messiah. In Amos 8:9, the Lord says, "I
will cause your festivals, I will turn
your festivals to mourning. I, you know,
your new moons, your Sabbaths, and so
forth, he says, I will clothe the
heavens with sackcloth." Right? At that
time, I will I will cause the sun to go
dark at midday, meaning noon, and I'll
make it a time of morning for an only
son.
This time that Isaiah is talking about
when the heavens would be clothed with
sackcloth
with blackness, the the prophet Amos
identifies as or says will take place at
noon and will be a time of morning for
an only son. The Hebrew word is yahed.
And the Greek term that's used to
translate that, it's used 12 times in
the Old Testament. in all of its
occurrences. There's two there's two
different words that are used different
places in the Greek translation.
Sometimes it uses the word agape which
means beloved son. Other times it uses
the word monogan which means only
begotten son. And so Amos 8 tells us
that this will coincide with the death
of God's only begotten son. Well, notice
how Isaiah goes on. The Lord God, it's
the servant speaking, has given me the
tongue of disciples that I may know how
to sustain the weary one with a word. He
awakens me morning by morning. He
awakens my ear to listen as a disciple.
The Lord God has opened my ear, and I
was not disobedient, nor did I turn
back. I gave my back to those who strike
me, and my cheeks to those who pluck out
the beard. I did not cover my face from
humiliate humiliation and spitting. For
the Lord God helps me, therefore, I am
not disgraced. Therefore, I have set my
face like flint, and I know that I will
not be ashamed. He who vindicates me is
near. Who will contend with me? Let us
stand up to each other. Who has a case
against me, let him draw near to me.
Behold, the Lord God helps me. Who is he
who condemns me? Behold, they will all
wear out like a garment. The moth will
eat them. He here refers to them as that
which those which are going to pass away
along with the former things along with
the old covenant along with all the
things that are associated with it that
are distinctive to it. Who is among you
that fears the Lord that obeys the voice
of his servant that should be
capitalized that walks in darkness and
has no light? Let him trust in the name
of the Lord and rely on his God. Behold,
all you who kindle a fire, who encircle
yourselves with fire brands, walk in the
light of your fire, and among the brands
you have set ablaze. This you will have
from my hand you will lie down in
torment. So all of this is associated
with the servant. One more servant text
before moving on.
And I know you're all just chomping at
the bit for me to start making
application of this, tying things
together, relating this to the Sabbath.
So bear with me. Bear with me. Here's a
text, a servant text that you all should
know. And again, it should be
capitalized. It's uh
lamentable that I didn't capitalize it.
This text of all text ought to be
capitalized. This is the servant text
par excellence, right? This is the
locust class with respect to the servant
and his mission. With respect, in fact,
to his identity and his mission. Here it
says, "Behold, my servant will prosper."
Again, I'm I'm hoping everybody is is
picking up and you know in in all of
this is being embied, right? I'm hoping
that you're inculcating all of this
because the words, the language,
everything is important. Okay, here it
says, "Behold, my servant will prosper."
Okay, on the one hand, he's called my
servant. So it's evident that he's
distinct from the speaker who is of
course the Lord God here. He's somebody
personally distinct from the Lord God
but not on that account a non- divine
figure because it goes on to say he will
be high and lifted up and exalted
exceedingly. Now, I've given you the
Hebrew more literally than it is found
in the NAS that I'm I have on the
screen. In Hebrew, it uses three terms
for elevation. Throughout Isaiah,
especially in combination, these terms
are used over and over again, and
they're used for the Lord. In Isaiah 6,
it says, "I saw the Lord high and lifted
up, and the train of his robe filled the
temple." Okay, so this is language that
Isaiah often uses for the Lord. In fact,
if you look at Isaiah 2:11 and Isaiah
21:17, we're told that this language is
only properly used for the Lord. Isaiah
says that in the future on that day, the
Lord will humble all the proud, all
those who are lofty in their own eyes,
and he alone will be high and lifted up.
He alone will be exalted in that day.
Well, here Isaiah says
not having he's not this is not Isaiah
having a falling out with himself quite
consistent with himself. Isaiah says
that the servant will be high and lifted
up and greatly exalted because Isaiah
understands that the servant of the Lord
is not merely a servant though he is
that he became such for us for us men
and our salvation. He came into the
world he took upon himself the nature of
the servant but he is more than that.
He is more than that as would appear
outwardly to people by his exaltation.
He is himself the Lord God. He would be
exalted to his rightful place. But now
in our nature, right now as the one who
bears our very nature, he would be
exalted into heaven. But Isaiah said
this would be true of the Lord alone in
the future. Well, here he says, "Behold,
my servant will prosper." The the Hebrew
term here it it literally it says behold
my servant will be wise or will deal
prudently. The idea is not that the
reason it's rendered prosper here is it
it gets to the point that's that's in
view. It it the idea is my servant
you might say who is the very embodiment
of wisdom. He will act in such a way
that he will be successful. What he does
will be so wise. Remember wisdom is not
merely knowing something but it's the
application of knowledge to specific
situations. This one will be so prudent,
so wise that he will know exactly what
to do. He will be effective. He will
accomplish exactly what he sets out to
do. My servant will prosper.
He will prosper. Just as many were
astonished at you, my people, so his
appearance was marred more than any man,
his form more than the sons of men. Thus
he will sprinkle many nations. Kings
will shut their mouths on account of
him. Remember what it said back earlier
in Isaiah when it says that kings will
see will arise and then bow down to him.
Same thing is stated here. But notice it
talks about this servant suffering. It
even calls him in verse one, the arm of
the Lord. Who has believed our message?
To whom has the arm of the Lord been
revealed? For he grew up before him like
a tender chute. The antecedent of he
here is the arm of the Lord. The servant
of the Lord is called the arm of the
Lord. He's the one who accomplished the
original exodus from Egypt,
foreshadowing his yet future and greater
work of redemption, which is in view
here in passages like the servant songs
in Isaiah 42, 49, 50 as well as 52 and
53. All right.
So, I'm hoping you all get the points
that I've been making from Isaiah. One
one more point from Isaiah and uh I'll
move on to some observations I want to
make about or from the Psalms. Then I
want to read a quote from Ucius and then
I'll start tying this all together. So
bear with me.
One of the things connected to this work
of the servant, I mentioned that it says
back in Isaiah that he's going to cause
rivers to uh flow in the wilderness. I
said that's an idiomatic expression for
the great promise of the outpouring of
the spirit.
Here it says it explicitly in Isaiah 44.
Now listen, O Jacob my servant and
Israel whom I have chosen here servant
is a reference to Israel the nation.
Thus says the Lord who made you and
formed you from the womb who will help
you. Do not fear, oh Jacob my servant
and you Jesheran whom I have chosen.
Jesan is an ancient name for Israel. For
I will pour out water on the thirsty
land and streams on the dry ground. I
will pour out my spirit on your
offspring and my blessing on your
descendants. So the Hebrew parallelism
in Hebrew poetry, it it works by way of
parallelism. There's different kinds of
parallelism. This would be an example of
what's called synonymous parallelism. So
what's stated in uh certain verses is
then repeated uh differently and what's
stated differently is bringing out the
meaning of the former statement. So here
I'll pour out water on the thirsty land
streams on the dry ground is interpreted
by Isaiah as a reference to the
outpouring of the spirit. So in
connection with this new thing that God
is going to do this better exodus better
redemption better co I hope I hope this
I'm beating this like a drum. I'm I'm
hoping you're hearing all this. The
servant, this new servant, this new
Moses, who's going to come, who's going
to bring redemption, who's going to
bring about the forgiveness of sin,
who's going to establish a new covenant,
who's going to bring his law, who's
going to pour out his spirit. All this
stuff is being associated with him. Oh,
I mentioned the new law. Let me give you
a passage that
mentions it. This is uh
this is Isaiah 51. It says, 'Listen to
me, you who pursue righteousness, who
seek the Lord. Look to the rock from
which you were heuned. Again, a title
given to God at the Exodus. And to the
quarry from which you were dug, look to
Abraham, your father, and to Sarah, who
gave birth to you and you pain. When I
when he was but one, I called him. Then
I blessed him and multiplied him.
Indeed, the Lord will comfort Zion. He
will comfort all her waste places, and
her wilderness he will make like Eden,
and her desert like the garden of the
Lord. Joy and gladness will be found in
her thanksgiving and sound of a melody.
A new song perhaps. Pay attention to me,
oh people, oh, oh my people, and give
ear to me, oh my nation. For a law will
go forth from me, and I will set my
justice for a light of the peoples. My
righteousness is near. My salvation has
gone forth, and my arms will judge the
peoples. The coastlands will wait for
me. And for my arm they will wait
expectantly, which I've argued is the
coming Messiah. Lift up your eyes to the
sky. Then look to the earth beneath. For
the sky will vanish like smoke, and the
earth will wear out like a garment, and
its inhabitants will die in like manner.
But my salvation will be forever, and my
righteousness will not wain. Listen to
me, you who know righteousness, a people
in whose heart is my law. Do not fear
the reproach of man, nor be dismayed at
their revilings. For the moth will eat
them like a garment, and the grub will
eat them like wool. But my righteousness
will be forever and my salvation to all
generations. Okay? So, I don't think I
need to repeat all the sorts of motifs
that are associated with this. I've said
it several times now. You know the
message of Isaiah. You know what he said
is going to happen in the future. You
heard the language that he uses for
this.
Now, I want to uh
skip past those and look at a couple of
Psalms.
All right. I don't see much chatter in
the in the comments section, but I
assume that there are people that are
still listening.
What I want to do is I I want to look
for a moment at some of the Psalms
because it's my contention
even though people will often quote the
Lord Jesus in Luke 24 where he says that
everything written about me in the law
of Moses and in the prophets and in the
Psalms has to be fulfilled.
People will often quote that.
But it it seems to me lamentably that
their their understanding of the
implications of that are their
understanding is far too small. Their
understanding is far too small. Usually
people cite that if if they're trying to
talk about how some psalm is messianic,
they'll cite that as though, you know,
this is the time to cite this because
this is one of those occasional psalms
that talk about the Messiah. And so they
might think for example Psalm 2 is about
the Messiah. Psalm 16, Psalm 22, you
know, few other psalms are about the
Messiah. That's not the point of Luke
24. The part the point about Luke 24 is
that the whole warp and woof of the Old
Testament, the law, the prophets, the
writings, everything is about Jesus.
Now, obviously, I can't demonstrate all
of that right now, but I do want to
bring the Psalms into this. And so, I
want to show you something relevant to
this point as a setup to I want to look
at Psalm 92 because then I want to quote
a a statement by that will get us into
the whole Sabbath issue, new covenant
worship, and so forth. Remember, I'm
building here. We're building together.
If you're listening with me, we're
you're laboring with me. We're building
together. So, we'll get there. Uh,
if you if you look at the book of
Psalms,
you you might be under the impression,
as so many are, that it's while while
the Psalms are inspired,
there's no rhyme or reason to their
organization. Okay? They're a
haphazardly arranged collection. Okay?
So, there's there's no flow to the
Psalms. There's no reason why
Psalm 1 and two and three and four
follow each other or uh you know there
there's just no rhyme or reason to the
organization of them. Well, that should
strike you as patently false just from
this observation which so many people
don't know about, but it's right there
in your Bibles. If you were to open up
your hard copies, yeah, I can't show you
this in many electronic versions because
they dropped this for whatever reason.
It's unfortunate because it's part of
the text.
in in your hard copies at the right
before Psalm 1, it says book one.
Okay? If you proceed up through Psalm 41
and look between 41 and 42, you'll see
it says book two.
The the psalter, what I'm driving at, is
actually a collection of five books.
It's patterned after in this regard the
Torah, the five books of Moses. There
are five books of Moses. There are five
collections of Psalms. I mentioned that
David is that figure in the Old
Testament who comes second to being uh
to Moses in being called the servant of
the Lord. Well, David's the primary
author of the book of Psalms. According
to 2 Samuel 23, and I don't have time to
argue the grammar here, but according to
2 Samuel 23, David was raised up by God
concerning the anointed one of the God
of Israel, the the uh the anointed one
of the God of Israel, the delightful one
of of Israel's psalms. Okay. What 2
Samuel 23 is saying is that one of the
reasons God raised up David was
precisely so that he would pen the
Psalms. Just like God raised up Pharaoh
for the reason that he had in showing
his mighty power and saving arm, his
saving strength, God raised up David for
among other reasons to speak of the
Messiah in his songs. That one whom God
promised him in 2 Samuel 7 would be the
heir from his loins who would be David's
son and God's son, right? The anointed
one, the king who would sit on an
eternal throne. Okay. So, David is the
primary author of the Psalms. You have
Davidic collections in the psalter
spread throughout it and and they're
collected. I mean, they're what I'm
getting at is they're they're they're
grouped together. So, for example, 1- 4
are all Psalms of David. If you look at
the superscriptions of the Psalms 3
through 41, they all say uh le Davidid
uh of David. Right now, somebody might
say there's an exception over Psalm 10,
over Psalm 33. They don't have a
superscription.
I don't have, again, I don't have time
to get into this, but the fact of the
matter is Psalm 10 is a unit with Psalm
9. Psalm 33 is a unit with Psalm 32.
This is not really debated by scholars.
So, I'm not just making claims here.
This is this is well established, easily
argued. These are a unit. They're
counted together even by Jews. If you
were to pick up the septagent for
example, that's the reason there's a
difference in the numbering in the
septagent between the some of the psalms
and how we number the psalms because
they grouped the psalms together
differently. So psalm 10 goes with nine,
psalm 33 goes with 32 and psalm 9 and 32
are said to be psalms of David. Well the
exception is psalm 1 and 2. Now I think
they're psalms of David but you don't
have a superscription over them and
that's to set these two psalms off as
the introduction to the psalter. Okay.
So Psalm 1, what I'm draw, I'm going to
tell you right up front here what I'm
arguing. Okay? What I'm arguing is that
Psalm 1 and two belong together
and they're about the same figure.
That's why I have the word man
capitalized here.
How blessed is the man. Psalm 1 is not
talking about people in general. Whoever
this is true of, right? Whoever doesn't
walk in the counsel of the wicked or
stand in the path of sinners or sit in
the seat of scoffers. That's the way a
lot of people read this that it's just a
generic description of a righteous
person. So anybody of whom this is true
that don't walk, stand, or sit right in
the counsel of the wicked or the path of
sinners or the seed of scoffers. Well,
that's who it's talking about. Well,
that's that's not what this psalm is
doing. It's talking about a particular
man, a man we learn more about in Psalm
2 and more about throughout the rest of
the psalter. Now, why would I say that?
Well, for one, this man is contrasted
not with uh well, look at verse four. It
says, "The wicked are not so." So, the
the blessed man is contrasted with the
wicked. The blessed man is contrasted
with the wicked. Notice that the wicked
are plural. It's not a generic way of
referring to the wicked. It's the wicked
plural. Why is it in the singular with
respect to the blessed man, but in the
plural with respect to the wicked,
unless it's talking about a particular
righteous man? Notice what it says about
this blessed man. Not only does he not
associate in uh ungodly ways with the
wicked, it doesn't mean that he can't
ever eat with them or talk to them. It's
saying that he doesn't take part in
their counsel. He doesn't uh you know
occupy their their scoff the seats that
they they they sit in that he's not
taking their counsel and scoffing with
them. But it says in verse two, his
delight
is in the law of the Lord and in his law
he meditates day and night. Here the
English does not get the Hebrew syntax
right. Here it does not get the Hebrew
syntax right. It it says in the Hebrew
in the law of the Lord is his delight
that is the blessed man and in his the
blessed man's law he meditates day and
night. Why is this significant? Okay.
Well, couple things here.
After the Torah, the first five books,
we read about Joshua taking over as
Moses successor. Remember that Moses
changed Joshua's name from Hoshia to
Yahosua.
He changed it from a word meaning
salvation to Jehovah is salvation. The
very name of the Lord Jesus. Right? When
it's translated
eventually uh goes through various
languages gets to us in English we say
Jesus but the original Hebrew would be
Yahosua meaning Jehovah saves or Jehovah
is salvation.
Moses who said that there's a future
figure coming after him who'd be uh the
one to realize all the redemptive
purposes of God. He renames Joshua as a
type and shadow of this Joshua as the uh
the type of the for a forerunner of that
coming one is renamed.
And we're told in Joshua 1 that he
meditates on the law of God day and
night. That's what he was called to do.
Well, here we're told of this blessed
man in this five-fold book patterned
after the law of Moses. We we're told
that this blessed man, the true new
Joshua, the true Moses, we're told that
the law in which he meditates is not the
law merely of the Lord. It is the Lord's
law, but it's his law. Okay? Again, this
is not this is not something that can be
challenged on the grounds of Hebrew
grammar. I know that I've said a lot of
stuff that somebody might say is, you
know, is he speculating? Is he out on a
limb? This is beyond question, right?
This is strictly grammatical the point
that I'm making. So, I'm not even trying
to draw a conclusion
when I say that the antecedent of his
law is the righteous man
and not the Lord. the righteous man is
the one who's uh is in view and it
refers to his law. And you you can not
only establish this grammatically, but I
mean you could turn to Jewish sources.
For example, no person is considered of
greater weight to Jewish people when it
comes to Hebrew grammar than Rashi,
right? Rabbi Schlommo. Rashi is the
cream of the crop when it comes to
grammar. Rashi himself admits that when
it refers to his Torah here, his law,
it's referring to the righteous man, the
blessed man. It's his law. Now, he tries
to get around the implications of this,
but grammatically he can't but agree
here. This is the righteous man that's
in view. Notice, he will, watch this. He
will be like a tree f firmly planted by
streams of water which yields its fruit
in its season and its leaf does not
wither and in whatever he does he
prospers.
Are you hearing the echo of Isaiah 52?
Behold, my servant will prosper. He's
the one that will lead the new Exodus,
right? He's the true new Moses. Well,
here you have it in Psalm 1 already.
You're being introduced to the blessed
man, the man who's coming and who
meditates in his own law, right? He's
coming and he's going to prosper. He
doesn't sit in the seat of scoffers,
right? He's contrasted with the wicked.
They'll be like chaff which the wind
drives away. Right? What do we read in
Psalm two? In Psalm two, you have all
kinds of things that are stated about
the blessed man. By the way, in Psalm 1,
it begins, "How blessed is the man." You
actually have an inclusio. This is one
of the reasons why I say that it's one
and two go together. And and Jewish
sources say these go together as well.
The Genesis Rabba or excuse me, the the
midrash here on this
uh not Genesis Raba, but the the midrash
on this on the Psalms says that there's
an inclusio in Psalm 1 and two. It
begins by saying, "How blessed is the
man who does not walk in the counsel of
the wicked." But then Psalm 2 ends.
Notice how Psalm 2 ends. It says, "Do
homage to the son, Nashkubar, literally
kiss the son that he not become angry
and you perish in the way, for his wrath
may soon be kindled. How blessed are all
who take refuge in him." You see what's
happened here? If you read these two
psalms together, then you understand
number one that the blessed man is the
son, the anointed one of Psalm 2. And
others are blessed by virtue of being in
him. How blessed are all who take refuge
in him. So you shouldn't think of the
Psalms as first of all about you, but as
first of all about the Messiah. And you
shouldn't think of the Psalms as first
of all about David or Solomon or anybody
else. The Psalms are esqueological. They
are messianic. They're talking about the
greater David, the greater Moses, the
the true servant of the Lord, the new
Joshua, the person who would bring about
a better redemption. That's what they're
all about. The anointed one. Okay,
notice how it begins. Why are the
nations in an uproar? The peoples
devising a vain thing. The kings of the
earth take their stand. and the rulers
take counsel together against the Lord
and against his anointed
Messiah, saying, "Let us tear their
fedters apart and cast away their courts
from us." He who sits in the heavens
laughs, the Lord scoffs at them. Notice
Psalm 1 says, "The righteous man does
not sit in the seat of scoffers." Here
in verse four, it says, "He who sits in
the heavens laughs. The Lord scoffs at
them. Then he will speak to them in his
anger and terrify them in his fury. As
for me, I have installed my king upon
Zion, my holy mountain. So, this king is
going to be established upon God's holy
mountain. Part of what's going to be uh
going to happen, we learn about this all
throughout the psalter is this one is
going to receive opposition,
but he's ultimately going to prosper.
He's going to be successful. He will be
established upon God's holy mountain.
Now ultimately my contention would be
that this is not the earthly Zion but
the heavenly Zion. Okay, of which the
earthly Zion together with its worship
was but a type and shadow. The earthly
temple along with all of the
ministrations that that would proceeded
there, the temple, right, the
priesthood, the sacrifices, all the
things that associated are associated
with it. All of those things are but
types and shadows of a heavenly and
future reality. Right? So there are
certain things that are true with
respect to the earthly worship that are
images of what's happening or what's
true in heaven and there are other
aspects of it that are pointing forward
to the work of the Messiah.
All right,
I better get moving here. I know that I
was told that uh I could go on and on as
long as I want because it's known that I
do marathons when I when I teach. Uh but
I I don't want to exasperate anyone. Uh,
I hope that if you don't have enough
time to listen to all this, uh, that
you'll break it up, you know, you'll
pause, you'll you'll come back and
listen more. Uh, you'll digest all of
this. But I'll I'll try and proceed a
little bit more quickly. Here's Psalm
92.
This is Psalm 92. Notice the
superscription.
Okay. The superscription says, "A psalm,
a song for the Sabbath day.
Now, throughout the psalter, I've argued
it's about the Messiah.
I I wish I could just sit here talking
about the Psalms because it's altogether
beautiful, right? To to watch how one
psalm after another is about the
Messiah. And believe me, it it's it's
endless. It's precious. the depths of it
are I I I think uh inexhaustible,
incapable of being plumbed. Uh but for
that reason, it's it's all uh I mean
it's it's refreshing. It's a joy. But uh
I hope from what little I've said that
you're this is resonating with you. You
understand this. When Jesus said that
the psalms were written about him, he's
not saying, "Oh, there's this psalm here
and then there's this other one and then
maybe a third or a fourth." That's not
what Jesus is saying. He's saying it's
about me. That's what this book is
about. In fact, it's about the Messiah
in more ways than one. This was his
meditation. This is what the Messiah had
on his lips. This is what he sang. This
is what he prayed. When he's praying on
the cross, there's a reason this book
was written for him. Right? This book
was written for him and for us because
it was for him. It is in him that all
the blessings in it are for us. Right?
So, it's all about him. In fact, the
adjacent psalm, Psalm 91, is a messianic
psalm. It's quoted in the New Testament.
Psalm 91, Satan says, "Cast yourself off
the pinnacle of the temple because it's
written, he'll give his angels charge
concerning you. They'll bear you up in
their arms." Right? It's a messianic
psalm. It's about the Messiah.
Immediately after this, in the psalter,
it talks about a song for the Sabbath
day. Right? Throughout the psalter, in
connection with him, we we're told about
a new song. Well, I want you to hear it
in this light. And then I'm going to
quote Ucius. And this gets us into
what I've been working up to. It says,
"It's good to give thanks to the Lord
and to sing praises to your name, oh
most high, to declare your loving
kindnesses in the morning and your
faithfulness by night with the 10
stringed loot and with a harp with
resounding music upon a liar. For you,
oh Lord, have made me glad by what you
have done. I will sing for joy at the
work of your hands." So the psalmist is
praising God for what he has done.
How great are your works, O Lord. Your
thoughts are very deep. A senseless man
has no knowledge. Nor does a stupid man
understand this. That when the wicked
sprouted up like grass, and all who did
iniquity flourished, it was only that
they might be destroyed forever more.
Sound like an echo of Psalm 2. And what
happens to the wicked who are like chaff
which the wind drives away who are
destroyed, right? It says, "But you, oh
Lord, are on high forever."
You, oh Lord, are on high forever. Who
is it that the Psalms envision being on
high, being lifted up, being exalted,
being seated at the right hand? Behold,
your enemies, O Lord, for behold, your
enemies will perish. All who do iniquity
will be scattered. But notice this, you
have exalted my horn like that of the
wild ox. I have been anointed with fresh
or with new oil.
Who is it that is in view here? Remember
I said that the psalter is about the
Messiah, about the anointed one, about
the son, about the blessed man. It's
already, this psalm already has alluded
to Psalm 1. Now you have a reference to
this one as anointed with fresh oil.
Says, "My eye has looked exaltantly upon
my foes. My ears uh my ears hear of the
evildoers who rise up against me. They r
this man, this blessed figure, this
anointed figure has wicked people that
rise up against him. He says, "The
righteous man will flourish like the
palm tree." Sound like Psalm 1. He will
grow like a cedar in Lebanon planted in
the house of the Lord. They will
flourish. Now it shifts to speaking in
the plural. Obviously, those who are
blessed in him, they will flourish in
the courts of our God. They will still
still yield fruit in old age. They shall
be full of sap and very green to declare
that the Lord is upright. He is my rock
and there's no uprightness or
unrighteousness, excuse me. There is no
unrighteousness in him. So that's Psalm
92. Okay. All that was the background.
All of that was the setup, the workup
to what I want to get into the the title
of the video. Now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to read a quote to you from
Ucius. Hey, this is a a statement from
Ucius that here's the the caveats that I
want to give at the beginning of this
because I know how people who argue for
perpetuating old covenant norms,
old covenant
ordinances,
old covenant statutes. I know how they
like to respond to any kind of petristic
statement or statement from a Christian
in history.
The first caveat is this. I'm not citing
this because I think the mere citation
of a Christian, even an early Christian
such as Ucius, establishes this. That's
not why I'm quoting this.
I want you to pay attention to the logic
of what Ucius is saying. I want you to
pay attention to the merit of it and
whether or not this has uh a firm
footing in the text of scripture itself.
Okay? So, I'm not trying to make Ucius's
weight carry this. I I think that it's
significant that we have an early
Christian saying this,
but I I don't by any stretch think that
this is a foundation for our belief. As
a Christian, I hold to the Protestant
principle, which I also think is a
ancient historic petristic principle,
the principle of solar scriptor that
scripture is the self-attesting and
allsufficient word of God. Right? It is
the infallible inherent
standard for all faith and practice.
Okay. So in quoting Ucius, let me say it
again. I'm not at all suggesting that
this makes it true. I'm appealing to
this
sure to say this shows that there's
historical precedence for this, but more
because I think it actually expresses
the the truth of the matter in in a very
uh clear way. But I also am quoting this
because I think it effectively answers
one of the things that you often hear
from those who want to perpetuate
observing Saturday as the Christian
Sabbath. Okay. The claim that is often
made by those who want to perpetuate
that is that the day was changed by
Constantine.
Now, Roman Catholics love when Seventh
Day Adventists and others say things
like, "It was changed by the Pope."
Okay? So, some will say that it was
changed by Constantine. Others will say
that it was changed by the Pope. Right?
Uh, cultic groups love this sort of
thing. They also say the Trinity. I'm
not saying the Adventists, but cultic
groups say the Trinity was invented
under Constantine, right? There are all
sorts of things. The cannon was invented
under Constantine. All that is hogwash.
Okay? It's not at all true. But Rome
loves this sort of thing because Rome
loves to arrogate to itself authority
that it doesn't have. It pretends that
it has the authority to change the day
of worship. I agree with 7th day
Adventist that Rome has no such
authority.
If the Sabbath has been changed, then it
could only be changed by God himself.
Okay? He is the Lord of the Sabbath.
Only he could counter man the day of
worship. Only he could make another day
hallowed. Right? Only he could bless
another day and say, "This is a day on
which you're to worship me." Right? Only
he could say, "That day on which you
formerly worshiped is no longer of any
account. Something greater has come."
Okay? Well, here's the quote from Ucius
with all that in mind. This is a
commentary of Psalm 92. It's a glorious
comment. Listen to this. The word he's
talking about the eternal logos, the
Lord Jesus Christ. The word by the new
covenant.
Note this, not Constantine,
not the pope. The word the logos himself
by the new covenant
translated and transferred the feast of
the Sabbath to the morning light and
gave to us the image of true rest, the
day of salvation, the Lord's day, the
first of the light on which the Savior
of the world after all his labors among
men obtained the victory. This is a long
sentence, isn't it? Well, I'm going to
stop there for a moment because I don't
want you to miss this. The word by the
new covenant transferred or translated
and transferred the feast of the
Sabbath. So, he's saying that the day
was no or that Saturday is no longer the
day of worship not because of a imperial
decree or a pronouncement but because
the word himself established a new
covenant.
It is the word then by establishing a
new covenant who displaced Saturday, put
it out of gear, rendered it no longer
binding on the Lord's people. Now, by
the way, I I want to make a a little
side comment here
that I I think ought to be unnerving to
those who want to perpetuate observing
Saturday, even apart from all that I've
said. Okay, this is a little aside here.
the the way that Sabotarians often
observe the Sabbath, as you know, is
from sunset to sunset,
from sunset to sunset, because they
believe that the Bible teaches that a
day begins at sunset, right? And ends at
sunset. So, a new day begins at the next
sunset. I I don't have time to go into
that either, but I want to point out
something to you really quickly that
ought to be unnerving to you, especially
if you are well in particular if you are
a sabotarian.
In John, notice that here refers to it
being transferred to the fe to the
morning light and gave to us the image
of true rest. What he's doing is he's
alluding to the resurrection of Christ
early on that first
Sunday morning, that eighth day, right?
That that first Sunday morning when
Jesus rose from the dead at, you know,
uh we're told uh early in the morning on
the first day of the week, Jesus rose
from the dead. That's what Ucius is
referring to. If you look at for example
John chapter
20,
I want you to notice something very
interesting. Now remember, according to
Satarians, as I like to call them, those
who insist that
the Sabbath is to be observed on
Saturday and from sunset to sunset in,
for some reason, my thing won't let me
see the Bible. Oh, there we go. All
right.
Uh, chapter 20. It says,
oops, I don't like this translation. So,
let me
let me change this real quick. Point
that I'm making isn't really dependent
on the translation, but all right, I'm
using the NAS
now. On the first day of the week,
notice it's the first day of the week.
Mary Magdalene came early to the tomb
while it was still dark. So, she gets
there while it was still dark. Okay? So,
the sun is is dawning. You got to read
all the accounts and you get the full
picture here, but she gets there, it's
still dark and the and the it's on the
verge of the the sun rising and so
forth. But notice this is called the
first day of the week. When she gets
there, when it's still dark, if you look
down at verse 19, remember what what's
happened. Jesus appears to the
disciples, but Thomas was not with them.
Okay? So Jesus appears to them again in
the evening. Okay? Now, if Satarians
were right,
now that it's evening, right, it went
from they were there at uh the uh in the
early morning on the first day of the
week when it was still dark. Now, we're
told that it was evening. So, it should
be a new day, shouldn't it? Notice what
John 20: says. So when it was evening on
that day, the first day of the week,
when the doors were shut where the
disciples were for fear of the Jews,
Jesus came and stood in the midst and
said to them, "Peace be with you." The
point that I'm making here is that
according to John 20, that first
Sunday, the day of the resurrection,
began in the morning before it even
became light as the sun was dawning. and
it was still the same day in the
evening.
That means that every person who's
observing the Sabbath, who thinks it's
Saturday from sunset to sunset, isn't
following the New Testament
because the New Testament does not teach
that a day begins at sunset. And I could
show you this repeatedly throughout
scripture. It is true that there's
certain events that are to be celebrated
from sunset to sunset, but it's a far
cry from that to say that a a day in the
Bible begins at sunset and uh ends at
sunset. But in any case, Sunday is
measured from I mean the the new
covenant uh measures things from uh
morning to morning. All right. So yia
says that by the new covenant he changed
the day of worship. Okay. And it says
after all his labors among men. Now,
there's a lot of stuff packed into this
that is why I find it so rich when he
says that this was changed by him
establishing a new covenant. Remember
what the whole of Hebrews is all about.
The Hebrews is talking about the Lord
Jesus who originally created the world
in the beginning doing something to
bring about a new creation and
fulfilling the the shadows of the old
covenant.
Remember when God created the world,
we're told that he worked for six days
and then rested on the seventh. Right?
That's where we get in the fourth
commandment as it's stated in Exodus 20
the idea annexed to the commandment
right annexed joined to the commandment
as its rationale is the statement right
that you're to remember the Sabbath day
for in six days the Lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that is in them
right that's the reason that's given for
observing Saturday because God created
in six days and rested on the seventh
now Deuteronomy 5 which which is a
restatement of the decalogue of the ten
commandments gives another reason namely
because God redeemed them from Egypt. So
you have creation and redemption given
as the reasons for the fourth
commandment. The reason they were to
observe a Sabbath rest on the seventh
day of the week is because of God's work
in creation and God's work in
redemption. Okay? So because he created
the world in six days and rested on the
seventh and because he delivered them
from Egyptian bondage. But remember, all
of that was typical of a new creation.
Something better that God was going to
do, right? A new creation was going to
dawn upon them. How? Through the the
servant, through the Messiah, through
the savior, the new Moses, he was going
to do a new creation work. And that
would in the very logic of it bring with
it a new priesthood, a new uh way of
worshiping God that is no longer
according to the old. Right? There would
be a new way of worshiping God, which
would include
the exclusion of the old covenant day,
Saturday. Think about how the author of
Hebrews begins
when he's about to launch into his
discussion of how Jesus has established
the new covenant, how Jesus has brought
to fulfillment the realities
foreshadowed, how Jesus has done away
with the priesthood, the sacrifices, and
all of the old covenant ways of worship.
How does he begin that? He says, "In the
past, God spoke to our forefathers
through the prophets at many times and
in various ways. But in these last days,
he has spoken through his son." The note
that the author is striking here is a
note of finality.
You're supposed to think of the old
covenant as incomplete, as imperfect.
Right? In the past, God spoke at many
times in various ways. But definitively
now in these last days, he has spoken.
Okay, the grammar in Greek indicates
this is with finality. He has spoken
through his son, right?
Through whom he made the worlds. It says
he is the image or the radiance of his
glory, the exact representation of his
nature. So you're told that this is the
one through whom God made the worlds,
the original creation. But then it goes
on to say what? When he had provided
purification for sin, his new covenant
work, this is the reality at the
foundation of the new covenant. When he
had provided purification for sin, he
sat down, he rested, he sat down at the
right hand of God.
The the point that you're supposed to be
thinking here is Old Testament
anticipated this. God worked. He rested.
Okay? The Psalms even speak of this as
God being seated, mounting his throne as
it were. God rests after he creates the
world. Here's the Lord Jesus, the
original creative agent who again comes
into the world. This time now to
recreate it, to make it new. How's he
going to do that? by redeeming it by his
death. After he completed that work, his
work was finished and he was seated at
the right hand of God. Okay. Now, what
day do we connect with that?
I'm not yet quite to the Sabbath, but
what day do we connect with that? On
what day did Jesus triumph over the
grave? On what day did the new Exodus
come to pass?
Obviously, it's on the Lord's day, the
first day of the week,
the morning light. It was on that day,
the Lord's day, that the Lord Jesus rose
again from the dead. And it it's
striking when you look at the
post-resurrection appearances.
We're not told in every case what day it
was, but every time we are told, it's
always on a Sunday, right? all of the
post-resurrection appearances of Christ
for which we can determine which day it
is was a Sunday.
Okay, that's the day when the the hope
of the disciples which had been dashed
to the ground when Jesus was crucified
and laid smoldering there for three
days, right? Their their hope, it was on
that day that their hope sprang eternal.
It was on that day that their hope was
renewed. When Jesus triumphed over
death, hell in the grave, when he
triumphed over Satan, on that day, the
first day of the week, it was on that
day that he appeared to them. And it was
on that day that all of the successive
appearances that are mentioned to us
when we're given their day, it was
always on that day. Don't you think the
disciples would have come to start
thinking, I sure would have, right? If
if the Lord Jesus would kept appearing
on that day, I think I'd start getting
ready for Sunday. I think I'd start
saying, "Hey, wait a minute. I'm sensing
a pattern here. Jesus appeared to us
three days later on the first day of the
week on Sunday. He appeared to us again
in the evening that Sunday. The next
time he appeared to us was on a Sunday.
And he appeared to us again on a Sunday.
On a Sunday, always a Sunday. Sunday
comes again. I think I'd be getting
ready, meeting together with the
disciples, and saying, "I hope we're
meeting with Jesus this Sunday." Right?
And that really is the whole point of
our worship every Lord's day that we are
meeting together as the people of God to
celebrate our Lord's triumph and to do
so in communion with him. Right? Well,
it's also on that day that the church
uh uh is is uh if you will
uh born a new. It's on that day that the
Holy Spirit descends upon the church.
So, it's the day of the resurrection.
It's the day of all the
post-resurrection appearances, as much
as they're named. It's the day of
Pentecost, right? Everything is taking
place on this momentous day. This is the
day that the Lord has made as the
psalmist said, Psalm 118, we will
rejoice and be glad in it. This is the
day when a new song was put into our
mouths. Okay? It's that day. But let's
let's go on with notice what he says.
He says, 'The first of the light on
which the Savior of the world after all
his labors among men obtained the
victory over death and passed the
portals of heaven, having reached or
achieved a work superior to the six days
creation on this day, a superior work.
Shouldn't there be a day to mark this?
And received the divine Sabbath and the
blessed rest. He's talking about the
eternal Sabbath here, the rest that we
have in Christ. When the father said to
him, "Sit at my right hand until I make
your enemies your foottool. On that day,
which is the first of light and of the
true son, we also assemble after an
interval of six days and celebrate holy
and spiritual Sabbaths." Now, I want you
to note the language here. He's talking
about holy and spiritual Sabbath. This
is going to be relevant to the whole
question of new covenant worship.
By word and work, making confession to
the Lord and singing in the name of the
most high in the morning also with the
first rising of our light, we proclaim
the mercy of God toward us also his
truth by night, exhibiting a sober and
chasteed demeanor. All things, notice,
all things which it was the duty which
it was duty to do on the Sabbath, these
we have transferred to the Lord's day as
more appropriately belonging to it
because it has the precedence and is
first in rank and more honorable than
the Jewish Sabbath. For on that day,
he's in making the world, God said, "Let
there be light." And there was light.
He's saying even in the creation of the
world, it anticipates that this day is
more glorious. Right? Let there be light
and there was light. And on the same
day, the son of righteousness arose upon
our souls. Paul uses similar language
when he says that the light of the
gospel of the glory of God is shown into
our hearts. He's hearkening back to the
creation. He's saying that that day if
it as you were or is a way of
foreshadowing the gospel of Christ. But
Ucius goes on, therefore it is delivered
to us that we should meet together on
this day, and it is ordered that we
should do those things announced in this
psalm. Now, um I thought I had another
part from uh Ucius, but I guess I don't.
I'll just have to make the point without
him, which I can easily and will happily
do. But with all that in mind, I want
you to notice now what we get in in the
apostles.
Watch what now. I know a lot of what I'm
reading hopefully you've read before,
but I'm hoping you begin to see this in
its connectiveness, how it all relates.
I'm hoping you're seeing connections
that like you haven't seen before, and
you're understanding the logic of how
certain things work in a better way.
In first Corinthians, or excuse me, 2
Corinthians,
Paul says,
"Therefore, knowing the fear of the
Lord, we persuade men, but we are made
manifest to God, and I hope that we are
made manifest also in your consciences."
So, notice what Paul's saying here. He's
talking about being made manifest to
God. God knows the truth about the
apostles. He's hoping the Corinthians
do, too. Okay? God knows the truth. And
he's hoping that he's commended himself
to them in such a way that that they
know the truth about Paul and the other
apostles. He says, "We are not again
commending ourselves to you, but are
giving you an occasion to be proud of us
so that you will have an answer for
those who take pride in appearance and
not in heart." So others are uh putting
down the apostles, especially Paul, and
are vaunting themselves over and against
them. They're trying to lead the
Corinthians in in weward paths. Paul's
trying to keep them on the the straight
way. And so he's saying, uh, we're
manifest to God. God knows the truth
about us. He hopes that it's true for
them as well. He's not again trying to
give a full-blown apologetic for it. Uh
but he is trying to give them something
that they might use to defend Paul and
the other apostles against those who are
opposing their teachings, those who are
seeking to mislead people from the
straight way. Right? He goes on in verse
13, for if we are beside ourselves, that
is in the sight of others, it is for
God. That is, it's for his sake that we
appear to be foolish. If we are of sound
mind, it is for you. So if in truth we
are of sound mind, it's to your benefit.
even if it doesn't appear that way to
others. For the love of Christ controls
us, having concluded this, that one died
for all. Therefore, all died and he died
for all so that they who live might no
longer live for themselves, but for him
who died and rose again on their behalf.
Okay. So, in context, Paul's talking
about the message of Christ, which they
proclaim, which he hopes manifests them
as true apostles and keeps them from the
Corinthians from giving their ear to
strangers, to those who would lead them
in wrong directions. He see all of this
is connected with the death and
resurrection of Christ. Notice what Paul
goes on to say. Therefore, from now on,
we recognize no one according to the
flesh. Even though we have known Christ
according to the flesh, yet now we know
him in this way no longer. Therefore, if
anyone is in Christ, he is a new
creature. Literally in the Greek, a new
creation has come. It's saying that if
somebody's in Christ now, then it means
the new creation is here. Okay? Why is
this significant?
because it means well scripture looks
forward to the
creation of a new heavens and a new
earth. A consummated reality
in which all evil is put down.
God is reigning and with his people
everything is put right in the world.
Okay. While that is something envisioned
by the prophets,
because Christ has come into the world
and done that work, that is the
foundation for it. For those who are in
Christ, they're already participating in
the new creation. Okay? But notice how
Paul speaks of this. He says, "The old
things have passed away. Behold, new
things have come."
If you listened, as I mentioned and and
begged, pleaded with you to do, you
remember the language of Isaiah. He's
echoing Isaiah when he talks about the
old things passing away and new things
having come in Christ. New things have
come, the new creation, the new exodus,
the better redemption, the new covenant.
He says, "Now all these things are from
God who reconciled us to himself through
Christ and gave us the ministry of
reconciliation, namely that God was in
Christ reconciling the world to himself,
not counting their trespasses against
them, and he has committed to us the
word of reconciliation." So here Paul is
declaring in Christ the coming, the
ushering in of the new creation. Okay,
here's Ephesians 2. Notice what the
apostle says. You're going to start to
see why this all has relevance to old
covenant worship and new covenant
worship. In Ephesians 2, Paul says, "You
were dead in your trespasses and sins in
which you formerly walked according to
the course of this world according to
the prince of the power of the air of
the spirit that is now working in the
sons of disobedience." So Paul says this
is what was formerly true of the
Ephesians. It's still true of others who
are not like the Ephesians in Christ.
Okay, notice he says this uh you were
these things, right? You were these
things, but he says that these things
are still true of the sons of
disobedience.
Okay. So you were dead in your
trespasses and sins in which you
formerly walked according to the course
of this world according to the prince of
the power of the air of of the spirit
that is now working in the sons of
disobedience. Among them we too all
formerly lived in the lust of our flesh,
indulging the desires of the flesh and
of the mind and were by nature children
of wrath even as the rest. But God
note the adversative note the strong
shift here. But God being rich in mercy
because of his great love with which he
loved us even when we were dead in our
transgressions.
Notice God loved us when we were dead.
So there's nothing in us or done by us
that's in view here as the grounds for
God being moved to do this. Okay? God
was moved to this when we were dead in
our transgressions. We had nothing in
our favor. He made us alive together
with Christ. This is monogistic. It's
God's work. By grace, you have been
saved. He says, "And he raised us up
with him and seated us with him in the
heavenly places in Christ Jesus."
Historically, objectively, that happened
that first Sunday and on the day of
ascension. Okay? When Jesus ascended and
poured out the Holy Spirit, okay, we
were in principle, representatively
exalted together with Christ. Okay? This
becomes ours when the spirit applies it
to us through the effect, you know, the
effectual application of it to our
hearts by the spirit. We are brought to
newness of life. That's what Paul's
talking about here. He raised us up with
him and seated us with him in the
heavenly places in Christ Jesus so that
in the ages to come, he might show the
surpassing riches of his grace in
kindness toward us in Christ Jesus. For
by grace you have been saved through
faith,
and that not of yourselves, it is the
gift of God, not as a result of works.
so that no one may boast. For
we are his workmanship, created in
Christ Jesus for good works, new
creation,
which God prepared beforehand so that we
would walk in them. So again, Paul is
talking here about new creation. We
already participate in the new creation.
Though the new creation is yet to be
consummated, it has already been
inaugurated. We are in Christ. We
participate in him. We are now
worshiping by the spirit who is called
in Hebrews 6 the spirit of the age to
come. And we are participating in that
future age right now. Notice what Paul
goes on to say in connection with this.
Therefore, remember that formerly you,
the Gentiles in the flesh, who are
called uncircumcision by the so-called
circumcision, which is performed in the
flesh by human hands. Okay, here Paul
brings up circumcision. Now remember in
in gen gen uh well one of the things I
often hear sabotarians arguing is that
Saturday must continue to be binding on
God's people because it uses terms like
everlasting covenant, perpetual forever,
right? This this sort of language.
Well, one thing the New Testament is
clear on, and I'd argue the Old, if one
reads it rightly, and certainly the
apostles did, Christ did, and the
apostles are are his emissaries, his
authorized spokesman.
One of the things that we see in the Old
Testament is that the the circumcision
is called a everlasting covenant in your
flesh, a perpetual ordinance, something
to be done forever. So is the Sabbath,
right? So is the temple. So is the
priesthood. All of these things are
called perpetual, everlasting, forever.
Okay?
But the Old Testament
and the new all the more leads us to
think of this in a certain sense. Right?
I I I'll I'll make this more clear as we
proceed. But
the the basic point that I'm making
that's
relevant here already is
the same language used for the Sabbath
being perpetual is used for other things
that Paul and the apostles explicitly
tell us are no longer binding.
No longer the same exact language and
the New Testament itself could not be
more clear. And really, as I said, the
logic of the Old Testament is clear on
this. The old covenant sign of the
covenant circumcision
was an outward ordinance that signified
the need for a new heart.
In Deuteronomy 30, for example, Moses
said, "The Lord your God will circumcise
your hearts." He's pointing forward to
the future to to a future work that God
would do. Jeremiah picks up on this,
right? This is the language of Jeremiah
when he talks about the new covenant
when God will give you a new heart.
That's what circumcision pointed to. The
reality of circumcision is a new heart
is the new birth. That's what
circumcision signified. So in the sense
that the reality that it pointed to is
always a necessity and is what God is
doing in the Messiah and by his spirit
that in that sense certainly it is
perpetual. But the outward form, the
outward observance of circumcision is
not binding. Uh clearly the New
Testament teaches this and the Old
Testament teaches this by pointing
forward to it by referring to these
things as part of the old covenant and
by saying a new covenant is going to be
established, right? And so on and so
forth. But but clearly Paul says here
that those who were
but are no longer uh outside of Christ.
They were
uncircumcised in the flesh and still
are, but they're called uncircumcision
by the so-called circumcision. What
Paul's anticipating is the idea that the
people of God, not by outward ordinance,
the outward ordinance of circumcision,
but by the new birth, by regeneration,
by the work of the spirit, are the true
circumcision.
Right? Remember that you were at that
time separate from Christ, excluded from
the commonwealth of Israel, and
strangers to the covenants of promise,
having no hope, and without God in the
world. But now in Christ Jesus, here's
another glorious but. Just like the the
but in Ephesians 2:4, but now, right,
God being rich in mercy, here you have,
but now in Christ Jesus, you who
formerly were far off have been brought
near by the blood of Christ. For he
himself is our peace, who made both
groups into one, and broke down the
barrier of the dividing wall by
abolishing in his flesh the enmity,
which is the law of commandments
contained in ordinances,
so that in himself he might make the two
into one new man, thus establishing
peace. What wall, what partition is Paul
talking about here that stood between
Jew and Gentile? Clearly, it's the
ordinances of the Mosaic law, the the
temple, the sacrifices, the priesthood,
the the dietary regulations, the the
rules pertaining to clean and unclean
Sabbaths, all those things drew a
distinction between God's people and
those who are not God's people. Here
Paul is saying that middle wall, that
partition has been torn down in Christ.
Christ has made us one new man. We're
part of the people of God. His sacrifice
has brought all of this about. His
sacrifice has brought all of this about.
All right. He goes on, "And might
reconcile them both in one body to God
through the cross by it having put to
death the enmity. And he came and
preached peace to you who were far away
and peace to those who were near. For
through him we both have our access in
one spirit to the father." Notice this
is old covenant temple language.
It was the high priest that could access
God. Here Paul is identifying Christ as
the true sacrifice and by his means or
by the means of his sacrifice uh the
ordinances of the old covenant have been
disestablished. Uh he talks about us
being brought nigh and being made into
one new man and peace being established
all through the blood of his cross. And
it says that he he established peace and
he made an way of access for us in one
spirit to the father. And so notice what
only the high priest could do and that
only once a year under the old covenant
is now the the the privilege part of the
freedom of the children of God. All
believers now have free access to God.
Notice how this affects worship. Okay?
Notice how this changes things. For
through him we both have access in one
spirit to the father. So then you are no
longer strangers and aliens, but you are
fellow citizens with the saints and are
of God's household. having been built on
the foundation. Note the temple language
here of the apostles and prophets.
Christ Jesus himself being the
cornerstone in whom the whole building
being fitted together is growing into a
holy temple in the Lord. In whom you
also are being built together into a
dwelling of God and the spirit. So
Christ is the true temple. In him we are
the true temple. Christ is the true
Israel. In him we are the true Israel.
Christ is the one who is the true
sacrifice. In him we have the
forgiveness of our sins. Christ is the
one who establishes peace, who makes way
to the father, right? All of these
things are the fulfillment of what the
old covenant was only anticipating,
right? But couldn't realize. That's why
when the new covenant is established,
those old covenant modes of worship are
fundamentally altered, fundamentally
transformed. They're no longer binding
in their outward form. And they're no
longer limited to the high priest, no
longer limited to one time a year or any
of the other qualifications or
restrictions, right? The the the the
doors are flung wide open in the worship
of God.
Brother, one one question here that I
think pertains just to something that he
says when he says the the um back when
he's talking about the barrier, somebody
has a question here. And when it says
the law of commandments, he asks, "Does
that not include the 10?"
Okay. So here Paul's specific focus is
on the ordinances of the Mosaic law. It
doesn't simply say the commandments but
contained in ordinances.
Uh so again it's it's talking about the
old covenant mode of worship and how
that was fulfilled in Christ and how we
are now participators in uh the
covenants of the promise through Christ.
Right. So does that does that address
it? Uh I mean I could say more about it
but is that
yes thank you.
Okay. Yeah. So uh the the the special
focus here. Now understand though this
has implications for the the
commandments because
the ordinances of the law are there to
illustrate our need for redemption
precisely because the law condemns us.
The the moral law, right? The moral law
condemns us. And the ceremonial law
shows us the way of salvation because we
can't be saved by observing the
commandments. And and the ceremonies
can't save us either. They're they're
illustrative of the way of salvation.
They don't save of themselves. They
point to the way of salvation. And so
when Paul talks here about uh the enmity
being done away with and stuff like
that, I mean, it it still has
implications for the relevance of the
ten commandments to us. They no longer
have a condemning power over us. Right?
But now somebody might ask, well, isn't
the fourth commandment one of the 10?
And I think that's kind of what is in
view when when the questioner asks this.
I know that's the sort of thing that
sabotarians bring up all the time. You
know, it's one of the big 10, right? How
do you say this one's no longer binding
and the others are? It was etched in
stone, right? It's intended to be
permanent. Uh those sorts of things. So
one thing I would say there is it it
it's not necessarily the case that just
because
the fourth commandment is contained in
the decalogue that all aspects of it
were intended to be perpetual or that
all aspects of it are moral in nature
and not ceremonial. Okay? And what do I
what I mean is this. Well, first of all,
if you compare Exodus 20 to Deuteronomy
5, it's evident that even God himself
changes the wording between the uh the
first statement of the law and the
second statement. So, there's something
of a fluctuation that even God himself
countenances with respect to to this
law. Again, you'd have to go read these
that there's there's differences between
the first statement in Exodus 20 and its
restatement in Deuteronomy 5. This
indicates something I'm suggesting visav
the the the nature of the commands. So,
I do believe that the moral commandments
of God in as much as they are moral
reflect God's character, his unchanging
character, and therefore are perpetual
as they relate to our duty. Right? uh
God doesn't change and in as much as
moral commands are reflection of his
character then our duty in relation to
God as his image bearsers does not
change. The question is does the day on
which we're to worship him is that
itself moral or is that ceremonial? I
would say that to worship God which is
what the fourth commandment requires
that's a moral and therefore a perpetual
duty. We can't escape the necessity, the
obligation of worshiping God as his
creatures, as his imagebearers. But
Saturday in particular, is that itself
part of the morality of the commandment?
I would argue that it's ceremonial. And
one of the things that demonstrates this
is the very fact that God blessed the
Sabbath day. The reason that day became
the day on which we worship God is
because God himself set it apart. It
shows that it doesn't have that nature
of itself. that's not necessarily in
itself holy, right? And the world fell
and uh there's a new creation, right?
All the stuff I've been talking about.
And so, uh
the idea that the day on which we
worship him is itself a reflection of
God's character and his unchanging
nature and our perpetual duty. Just uh
uh I think flies in the face of
everything. And all that I'm saying here
ties into that, right? you uh
circumcision, temple worship, the
priesthood, sacrifices, all of these are
considered by Paul part of the same
package. Paul's even going to roll it up
into this as many of you know as I
proceed here. So, he's already said all
sorts of things in Colossians uh
or excuse me, I'm still reading
Ephesians.
Uh he says that uh we have access to
God. We're a new temple. Now, here's
Colossians.
Hey, watch what Paul does in Colossians.
Now, I know you guys have heard this
before. It comes up in the discussion
with Satarians,
but again, I want you to hear this now
with everything else in view that we've
talked about. Paul says in Colossians 2,
I want you to know how great a struggle
I have on your behalf. and for those who
are at Leodysia and for all those who
have not personally seen my face that
their hearts may be encouraged having
been knit together in love and attaining
to all the wealth that comes from the
full assurance of understanding
resulting in a true knowledge of God's
mystery that is Christ himself so Christ
himself is the mystery right he is that
revealed truth that God
uh brought about uh in the fullness of
time for our redemption ion. Okay.
Christ himself in whom Paul says are
hidden. All the treasures of wisdom and
knowledge. So all the treasures of
wisdom and knowledge are found in
Christ. Right? So the promises of God
are yes and amen in him. The the types
and shadows of the old covenant law were
pointing to him. He's the reality. He's
the embodiment. He's the substance of
them. Okay? In him are hidden all the
treasures of wisdom and knowledge. Paul
says,"I say this so that no one will
delude you with persuasive argument."
I say this so that no one will delude
you with persuasive argument. For even
though I am absent in body,
nevertheless, I am present with you in
spirit, rejoicing to see your good
discipline and the stability of your
faith in Christ. So all that Paul's
saying here, he's saying precisely to
arm the Colossians against those who
would mislead them, such as the
Judaizers or protonnostics or any of the
other groups that were around in the
first century. Paul is arming the
Colossians when he tells them that in
Christ is everything. Christ is the
embodiment of wisdom and knowledge. We
have all sufficiency in him. Paul is
saying he's arming them by this.
Therefore, as you have see received
Christ Jesus the Lord, so walk in him,
having been firmly rooted and now being
built up in him and established in your
faith just as you were instructed and
overflowing with gratitude. So he's
saying just as you've received Christ
Jesus the Lord, so walk in him. How did
you receive him? By faith. Verse seven
says, having been firmly rooted and now
built up in him and established in your
faith. Right? So you received him by
faith. Walk in him by faith. Okay? You
rooted in him and and are being built up
in him by faith. Right? So do this as
you began to do. Do it continually. See
to it that no one takes you captive
through philosophy and empty deception
according to the tradition of men
according to the elementary principles
of the world rather than according to
Christ. Here Paul uses a term
that is significant a a term that is
pregnant with meaning. It's the term
stokeia, the elementary principles of
the world. Okay, this this term is used
as a
further description of the tradition of
men or empty deception. Okay? Or the
philosophy that is not according to
Christ. Paul's not putting down
philosophy as such. There's a philosophy
that is consistent with Christ. It's
revealed by the apostles. But everything
that is not according to Christ, even if
it pretends to be but veers from it,
Paul refers to as empty deception, the
tradition of men, the elementary
principles of the world. Okay? Now, this
is important to get. Paul is saying not
to fall for this. Cling to Christ
because in him all the fullness of de
deity dwells in bodily form and in him
you have been made complete and he is
the head over all rule and authority and
in him you were also circumcised with a
circumcision made without hands in the
removal of the body of the flesh by the
circumcision of Christ. So here Paul
talks about the true circumcision being
that which was done or is done by the
spirit. It's not the outward
circumcision that sign of the old
covenant. It's done by the spirit. It's
signified by circumcision or was
signified under the old covenant. Uh but
now he says uh in Christ this is a
reality for us. We have the reality
signified by circumcision. Having been
buried with him in baptism, the new
covenant sign in which you were also
raised up with him through faith in the
working of God who raised him from the
dead. Now note note what Paul says in
this connection in this connection of
Christ as our sufficiency. In Christ as
the one in whom are deposited all the
treasures of wisdom and knowledge in
Christ as the one who is the fullness of
deity in bodily form. Right? In whom we
have the true circumcision
in connection with all of this and his
death and resurrection which we
participate in through faith signified
in baptism. He says, "When you were dead
in your transgressions and the
uncircumcision of your flesh, he made
you alive together with him, having
forgiven us all our transgressions,
having canceled out the certificate of
debt consisting of decrees against us,
which was hostile to us. And he has
taken it out of the way, having nailed
it to the cross. When he had disarmed
the rulers and authorities, he made a
public display of them, having triumphed
over them through him." So notice how
Paul in this context associates the
stokea, the elementary principles with
empty deception, the traditions of men
and
uh with the rulers and authorities that
were displaced by Christ. Okay, these
things were hostile to us, but they've
been done away with by the coming of
Christ. Christ has done away with them
and at the same time has triumphed over
principalities and powers. Why is all
that relevant? Well, we'll see more in a
bit. In verse 16, Paul says,
"Therefore," he's drawing a conclusion.
"Therefore, no one is to act as your
judge in regard to food or drink or in
respect to a festival or a new moon or a
Sabbath day."
Notice that in this context where Paul
is talking about how Christ has done
away with
uh or excuse me in this passage where
Paul sounding very much like when he was
talking to the Ephesians when Paul is
warning them against going back to their
former paganism,
he warns them against being persuaded by
empty deception, the traditions of men,
the elementary principles of the world,
the the reasoning of men, right? the
sorts of things they find
credible, plausible, foundational.
Right? In this very context, Paul says,
"Therefore, no one is to act as your
judge in regard to food or drink or in
respect to a festival or a new moon or a
Sabbath day." Paul is associating
the ordinances of the Mosaic law that
Christ did away with with the stokeia of
the pagans. This is not the only time
that Paul does this. I'm going to show
you another time where I think it's even
clearer and all the more devastating.
But here it's
true as well. He says, "These things
which are a mere shadow of what is to
come, but the substance belongs to
Christ." He goes on, "Let no one keep
defrauding you of your prize by
delighting in self-abasement and the
worship of angels, taking a stands on
fleshly visions and so forth, and not
holding fast to the head, from whom the
entire body being supplied and held
together by the joints and ligaments
grows with the growth which is from
God." He says, "If you have died with
Christ to the elementary principles of
the world, the stokeia,
why as if you were living in the world,
the old creation, do you submit yourself
to decrees such as do not handle, do not
taste, do not touch, which all refer to
things destined to perish with use,
right? The laws of clean and unclean in
accordance with the commandments and
teaching of men." Paul is here
associating this
these practices that were otherwise part
of the Mosaic law. Now that Christ has
come, he's associating them with the
stokeia, the elementary principles that
were true of these Gentiles when in
their former paganism. He says, "These
are matters which have to be sure the
appearance of wisdom in self-made
religion and self-abasement and severe
treatment of the body, but are of no
value against fleshly indulgence." Now,
I said that Paul will do this again.
Notice what Paul does in Galatians 4. If
it wasn't clear from Colossians 2,
hopefully it becomes clear to you from
Galatians 4.
Real quick, if you don't mind, will you
take this comment here? Um, he says,
"God rested, blessed, and sanctified a
specific day, calling that day the
Sabbath because in it he rested,
blessed, and sanctified. It wasn't the
first day commonly called Sunday."
Yeah. So I've already dealt with this in
principle. I pointed out that the old
covenant Sabbath was founded upon God's
work of creation and redemption. That's
obvious from the decalogue in both of
its statements. In Exodus 20, the first
statement has annexed to it that we are
to observe the Sabbath because in six
days God made heaven and earth and on
the seventh he rested. So creation in
the second statement of the law in
Deuteronomy 5, the reason given is
because he redeemed them from Egyptian
bondage. So creation and redemption are
the grounds for this. And that of course
is seen in what you're referring to in
in Genesis 2 when it talks about God
consequent upon uh his creating the
world rested on the seventh day and
blessed that day. So, I quite agree.
That's why the Sabbath was a ordinance
binding on the people of God. However,
all of that, as I said, you're probably
showing up late, so I understand. Go
back and listen. Uh, you know, you owe
it to yourself. I I'm I'm saying, you
know, maybe you'll you'll agree with me,
maybe you won't, but I think you owe it
to yourself to go back and listen
because I I laid a lot of groundwork for
this. The Old Testament in all of these
things is anticipating a new and better
creation, a better redemption, a better
covenant,
which was accomplished by the Lord Jesus
Christ, who consequent upon fulfilling
what was anticipated,
rose from the dead, and entered into his
rest on the first day of the week. It
was a new day in keeping with this new
and better redemption, this new
covenant. So Jesus by virtue of rising
from the dead and establishing a new
covenant has transferred all that was
formerly associated with the Sabbath but
now in its transformed and more glorious
uh associations uh to the first day of
the week. So I I think that answers it.
But
yeah, go ahead. One more here says,
"Pastor Rogers, where in Exodus or
Deuteronomy does it command uh I think
he me means us command us to worship?"
Well, if you're
specifically asking about the word I'm
regarding the Sabbath.
Oh, where does it say the Sabbath is a
day of worship?
Is that the question?
Yeah, I believe so. because we you
mentioned both the creation in in Exodus
being mentioned and then in Deuteronomy
it mentions redemption and um this was a
little bit earlier you had said
something about um worship also being
something tied to
uh I believe he said the fourth
commandment
that you said the fourth commandment
deals with worship. So I think he's
asking where uh in Exodus and
Deuteronomy does it say that the fourth
commandment is about worship.
Yeah. So,
first of all, I'd say the logic of it is
evident on the face of it. God's not
telling his people to be idle. That's
not the point. He's not saying sit
around and be a bunch of do nothings.
They're resting from their normal
employments, but that doesn't mean that
they're to be inactive toward the Lord.
They're to engage in worship. Now, you
you might just say, "Well, that's your
inference, but what what grounds do you
have for that?" Well, uh, one thing
would be that I I don't think that
the
worship of God, I have to do a little
building here for a second.
In the worship of God, we are not
permitted to do anything but what he
commands. Okay? So, follow me here for a
moment. We're not allowed to do anything
but what God commands. The evidence for
that would be, for example, the the
statements repeatedly found in the
prophets where God says things like,
"Who required this of your hands?" There
he's upgrading them for coming to him
and doing something he didn't command
them to do. Right? This is more I hope
you're following this carefully. This is
more than saying that you're not to do
in worship anything that God has
forbidden.
What I'm saying is according to the
prophets, you can't do anything in
worship that God has not required.
God alone tells us what we are to do in
worship and how we may approach him. And
the clear object lesson for this the
prime example of this is Nate Abanu in
Leviticus 10 when they thought it was a
good idea to bring unauthorized fire
before the Lord and the Lord consumed
them.
Okay. The Lord consumed them for
bringing unauthorized fire.
They did something that God did not
require. So the the point that the
principle that I'm establishing is that
God can only be worshiped according to
his own command. We don't have the right
to make up our own commands. Right? Now,
here's why I'm mentioning this.
The Jews came to practice, and I argue I
would argue that this is based in the
Old Testament. And it would take a while
to unpack it, but the Jews came to
observe
Saturday, the Sabbath, as a day not only
of resting from their worldly
employments, but of gathering together
and worshiping God, hearing his word
read, right? Uh singing uh and so forth.
That was a regular Sabbath practice. The
Lord Jesus Christ did the same thing,
did he not? Now, if God only allows in
his worship what he commands, then
clearly the fact that Jesus observed
this, engaged in synagogue worship shows
that it was a requirement that God
expected his people to be engaged in
worship. I think that's a very clear and
inescapable
uh point in favor of saying that Sunday
is a day on which God's people were to
worship him. It wasn't a day on which
they were simply to be idol. But besides
that, this
idea of worship is
uh it's not simply finding the word that
would establish it as as worship. when
people serve God that the word for
service is the word for worship. And so
clearly in the law of God when people
engage in a holy rest, not an idol rest,
a holy rest, it's uh it's an act of
service to God. It's repeatedly called
ser, you know, service. So it is worship
even if our translations don't always
render it that way.
What about if someone says, "But it says
in the Old Testament they weren't
supposed to leave their place on the
Sabbath." Doesn't that show that they
were sitting around idol?
Well, even then, it wouldn't prove that
they were idle. Um, one thing is
remember that the people of God were
supposed to uh always have the law of
God on their lips, right? Um, reads to
stay put and not leave your place. All
right. So, uh, every Pharisee would
agree with how you're apparently
understanding that, but I'll come back
to that. So, it it wouldn't follow
necessarily that if a person couldn't
ever leave their house, if that was
intended to be the the norm throughout
their generations, it wouldn't follow
that they're not supposed to be engaged
in worship and are supposed to be idle
in their tents, right? Because
the families of of of God are required
to meditate on his law, to talk about
his law, right? It's to be on their
lips. It is to be in they're to be
putting it into each other's ears,
right? When uh Deuteronomy 6 tells us
that we're to love the Lord our God with
all our heart, with all our mind, with
all our soul, and with all our strength.
And so that being the case, I mean
that's not limited to Saturday to be
sure, but for that very reason, right,
it it's also true on Saturday. It's it's
it's indiscriminate. It's to be done all
every day of the week. It says uh
the these words which I am commanding
you today shall be on your heart. You
shall teach them diligently to your sons
and shall talk of them when you sit in
your house
and when you walk by the way and when
you lie down and when you rise up. And
so if it is the case that you are
absolutely not supposed to leave your
dwelling place
at all uh times uh throughout all the
generations on Saturday.
It wouldn't follow from that that
Saturday isn't a day of worship.
According to Deuteronomy 6, these words
which I am commanding you today shall be
on your heart. You shall teach them
diligently to your sons and shall talk
of them when you sit in your house. And
so
if people are engaged in their normal
employments throughout the week, you can
see how that would take away from their
ability to fulfill that. They were still
called to do it while they're working as
much as they could. They were supposed
to have the law of God on their minds or
to talk about it with one another, but
clearly they would be distracted from
this. The nature of the work would would
draw away their attention from it. But
on the Lord's or on the Sabbath, when
they're required to cease from all their
labors, they could engage in this more
earnestly. So far from
Saturday under the old covenant not
being a day in which they're to be
engaged in the worship of God, the law
of God uh makes it clear that they are
all the more I think to be engaged in
his worship on that day. So I don't know
if there's anything you want to add to
that, but
maybe you stepped away. So I will I will
continue.
Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't realize that I
was muted. My my apologies. I was just
saying that I think it's important that
when we're talking about worship, you
hinted at this a little bit. Um
it's not necessarily what we always
stereotypically think of like leaving
and going to the church building and
that's exclusively what worship is by us
gathering for church service. Um that
obviously is worship, but uh we're
worshiping God daily in our lives. So
that can definitely be done at home. Um,
not we shouldn't, like you said, read
into that that that necessarily meant
sit at home idle doing nothing.
Yeah.
Um, all right. So, did I uh
adequately
You did. Yeah. Let's Let's continue with
Galatians 4 here.
All right. Uh,
hold on one second. Where was I? Um,
all right.
So, Galatians 4, I I had changed my
screen, so I had to come back to it.
Galatians 4. Note what Paul does. He
says, "Now I say, as long as the heir is
a child, he does not at all differ from
a slave, although he is owner of
everything." And now remember before I
said that Paul associated
the continued observance of old covenant
modes of of worship or old covenant
observances with what they had formerly
done in their pagan state. I want you to
notice that Paul says here that as long
as the heir is a child, he does not
differ at all from a slave. That is
outwardly there doesn't appear to be
much of a difference. the the true
difference arises or appears when the
son the heir attains to maturity. Okay?
When he enters into the full enjoyment
of what is his inheritance
but prior to that he seems to be very
similar outwardly to a slave. Now what's
the point that he's making here? Well
just keep reading. He's talking to
Gentiles but watch what he does. He is
under guardians and managers until the
date set by the father. So also we
Why does Paul say we addressing these
Gentiles?
He says so also we while we were
children were held in bondage under the
elemental things of the world. The
stokea.
But when the fullness of the time came,
God sent forth his son, born of a woman,
born under the law, so that he might
redeem those who were under the law,
that we might receive the adoption as
sons. Because you are sons, God has sent
forth the spirit of his son into our
hearts, crying, "Aba, Father. Therefore,
you are no longer a slave, but a son.
And if a slave, or if a son, than an
heir through God." So notice Paul here
associates the position of Jews under
the old covenant, right? Those who want
to maintain that. Now, uh he's likening
them to the the the Gentile or the the
Galatians.
I I sort of lost my own train of thought
there. He's he's likening
what was true of him as a Jew prior to
Christ
with what was true of the Gentiles prior
to being in Christ. Okay? So, he's
associating old covenant modes of
worship in this way now that Christ has
come with the same sorts of things that
were true of the pagans. They're they're
they're lumped together with the stokea,
the elemental things of the world. that
have been done away with in Christ.
Okay? In Christ, redemption has been
accomplished. We now have the adoption
as sons. We now attain to maturity. We
receive the inheritance. We have the
spirit of the age to come, right? The
spirit of adoption, right? And and
uh so notice now in light of this, okay?
Watch what Paul does throughout his
writings. Watch how Paul takes things
that were said of old covenant worship
and he begins to reinterpret them. Paul
begins to transform things that were
binding under the old covenant and he
turns them into
something in keeping with the new
covenant that has been brought by
Christ. Something in keeping with now
the work of the spirit in our hearts.
something now in keeping with the
transforming work that Jesus has wrought
in Romans 12. Notice what Paul says.
Therefore, I urge you, brethren, by the
mercies of God, notice he's talking to
all Christians, not to a special class
that we would call priests. He says,"I
urge you, brethren, by the mercies of
God to present your bodies a living and
holy sacrifice acceptable to God, which
is your spiritual service of worship."
Here Paul takes the language of
sacrifice under the old covenant, not
the guilt offering and so forth, but the
consecration offerings and that sort of
thing. And he applies it to all
believers. All believers are to offer
themselves as a holy sacrifice
acceptable to God. This is your
spiritual service of worship. The
worship of God under the old covenant
has now been, if you will,
spiritualized.
Not that they weren't ultimately
directed to this sort of thing even
then, but they were still uh uh taught
to do so
along the way by observing these uh
things under their old covenant forms.
But but Paul begins to take this
language, he co-ops it for our
observance to Christ.
He says,"Do not be conformed to this
world, but transformed by the renewing
of your mind so that you may prove what
the will of God is, that which is good
and acceptable and perfect." So again,
language of new creation. There has been
uh a transformation, a renewal that has
taken place. It's taking place in us.
And in accordance with this, we are to
offer our bodies a living and holy
sacrifice. No longer are those old
covenant sacrifices binding. No more is
it merely the priests that do it. It's
all the people of God and it's a
spiritual service of worship. Romans 15,
Paul says, "Concerning you, my brethren,
I myself also am convinced that you
yourselves are full of goodness, filled
with all knowledge, and able also to
admonish one another. But I have written
very boldly to you on some point so as
to remind you again because of the grace
that was given me from God to be a
minister of Christ Jesus to the
Gentiles, ministering as a priest the
gospel of God so that my offering of the
Gentiles may become acceptable
sanctified by the Holy Spirit. Now don't
misunderstand Paul here as though he's
saying that he's part of a priesthood
that is distinctive from that of all
other believers. Certainly Paul holds
office. He's a uh apostle. He's a uh
minister in Christ's church. But when he
refers to himself uh in this capacity
ministering as a priest, remember he
spoke in this way of all believers
already in Romans 12. And here he's
simply saying that what's true of all is
also true of me. But in this sense that
he's offering up the Gentiles as an
acceptable sacrifice sanctified by the
Holy Spirit. Once again, Paul takes the
language of old covenant worship and he
interprets it along new covenant lines.
Paul has transformed this rather the new
covenant or Christ by establishing the
new covenant has transformed it. Paul is
Christ's authoritative spokesman speaks
to it. Here is Philippians 2. So then my
beloved, just as you have always obeyed,
not as in my presence only, but now much
more in my absence, work out your
salvation with fear and trembling. Note,
not work for it, work out. God not only
justifies, declares righteous, but
causes those who are righteous in Christ
to grow in grace and holiness and in the
knowledge and fear of the Lord. So Paul
says, "Work out your salvation with fear
and trembling. For it is God who is at
work in you both to will and to work for
his good pleasure. Do all things without
grumbling or disputing, so that you will
prove yourselves to be blameless and
innocent, children of God above
reproach, in the midst of a crooked and
perverse generation, among whom you
appear as lights in the world, holding
fast the word of life, so that in the
day of Christ, I will have reason to
glory because I did not run in vain, nor
toil in vain. But even if I am being
poured out as a drink offering upon the
sacrifice in service of your faith, I
rejoice and share my joy with you all.
You too, I urge, rejoice in the same way
and share your joy with me. Notice again
how Paul uses old covenant sacrificial
language and he applies it to his gospel
labors. Okay, Paul has spoken of new
covenant duties in old covenant terms,
but clearly does not intend their
outward form as that which he's
referring to. He's not saying that he's
literally offering a drink offering.
Rather, he's being poured out as a drink
offering. Right? He's offering up the
Gentiles as a uh sacrifice to God.
Right? He is calling us to offer
ourselves as living sacrifices, as a
spiritual act of service. Okay? We are
the true circumcision. We have the
reality of the matter in ourselves.
Everything that is part and parcel of
this sort of thing in the Old Testament,
Paul takes up and transforms and applies
to our new covenant uh behavior.
Philippians 4, Paul says, "You
yourselves also know Philippians that at
the first preaching of the gospel after
I left Macedonia, no church shared with
me in the matter of giving and
receiving, but you alone. For even in
Thessalonica, you sent a gift more than
once from my needs. Not that I seek the
gift itself, but I seek the profit which
increases to your account. But I have
received everything in full and have an
abundance. I am amply supplied having
received from Apapraditis what you have
sent a fragrant aroma an acceptable
sacrifice well pleasing to God. So here
Paul refers to giving along these lines
and my God will supply all your needs
according to his riches and glory in
Christ Jesus. Now to our God and father
be the glory forever and ever. Amen.
Okay. Notice he refers to giving and
receiving in this way as a fragrant
aroma an acceptable sacrifice well
pleasing to God. 2 Timothy 4, Paul says,
"For I am already being poured out as a
drink offering, and the time of my
departure has come. I have fought the
good fight. I have finished the course.
I have kept the faith. In the future,
there is laid up for me the crown of
righteousness, which the Lord, the
righteous judge, will award to me on
that day. And not only to me, but also
to all who have loved his appearing." So
Paul again refers to himself as uh a
sacrifice. He's being poured out as a
drink offering, not a guilt offering,
but a drink offering. Here is Paul in uh
or excuse me the author of Hebrews. He
says remember those who led you who
spoke the word of God to you and
considering the result of their conduct
imitate their faith. Jesus Christ is the
same yesterday and today and forever. Do
not car be carried away by varied and
strange teachings. For it's good for the
heart to be strengthened by grace, not
by foods through which those who were so
occupied were not benefited. We have an
altar from which, notice, we have an
altar from which those who serve the
tabernacle, the earthly tabernacle, have
no right to eat. For the bodies of those
animals whose blood is brought into the
holy place by the high priest as an
offering for sin are burned outside the
camp. Therefore, Jesus also that he
might sanctify the people through his
own blood suffered outside the gate.
Through him, then let us continually
offer up a sacrifice of praise to God.
that is the fruit of lips that give
thanks to his name and do not neglect
doing good and sharing for with such
sacrifices God is pleased. So again,
notice how Paul takes the language of
the Old Testament uh temple sacrifice,
priesthood, all the ordinances of the
law and he applies them to Christian
duty, Christian behavior.
Now, why is all of this important? Oh, I
could go on quoting other passages where
the apostles do this. Uh, Peter does
this.
Um, oh, I guess I do have Oh, no, I
don't. Never mind. I thought I had
another part. What I want to do, if you
can, uh, you can remove that from the
screen.
What I want to do to sort of cap off
this
is
look at
Isaiah 56 and Isaiah 66. Two passages
that talk about the Sabbath. And I want
you to observe something in light of
what we've said. Remember this is
Isaiah. Isaiah has talked about a new
covenant, a new and better redemption.
He talks about the new and better Moses.
He talks about a new song being put in
our mouth. He talks about how the the
spirit is going to be given. He talks
about how the former things are going to
be forgotten. How the old covenant
together with its rituals, its
ordinances are going to be put aside,
put out of gear, rendered obsolete. In
in this context of Isaiah, we read in
chapter 56, notice what it says. And
remembering also, by the way, what we've
read in the apostles, circumcision is no
longer binding. Sacrifices are no longer
binding because of Christ. I want you to
hear this now in light of this. Okay?
What verses Uh well I'm just the whole
the whole chapter I'm going to I'll go
through. So Isaiah 56 verse1 it says
thus says the Lord preserve justice and
do righteousness for my salvation is
about to come and my righteousness to be
revealed. How blessed is the man who
does this and the son of man who takes
hold of it who keeps from profaining the
Sabbath and keeps his hand from doing an
evil. Let not the foreigner who has
joined himself to the Lord say, "The
Lord will surely separate me from his
people." Nor let the unic say, "Behold,
I am a dry tree." Now, oh, you're you're
you've got on the screen there. Okay.
So, this is where a lot of sabotarians
get all excited. It talks about the
Sabbath, right? And it's talking about
this in connection with the new thing
that God is doing. But notice how also
this chapter speaks.
So, I read through verse three. And in
verse four, if uh actually my site is
not as good if uh I'll try and read that
from your translation here. It says,
"For thus uh oh, thank you. Thus says
the Lord to the Unix." Now already you
should be thinking of this as
significant because under the law the
Unix couldn't participate in this way.
But God is specifically singling out the
Unix. There's something new, right? the
Unix who keep my Sabbath, who choose the
things that please me and and hold fast
my covenant. I will give my house and
within my walls a monument and a name
better than sons and daughters. Now
notice it's talking about them serving
in his house and within his walls. Under
the old covenant, this is a way of
referring to the temple. But we know
under the new covenant that this is no
longer a part of the new covenant. The
temple is no longer right. Paul refers
to the church as the new temple. Right?
Christ is the true temple ultimately.
John 2, John 4, right? Repeatedly Christ
is identified as the true temple.
Christians as those who are in him are
living stones who are being united to
him as the cornerstone. We are the
temple of God. He dwells in us by his
spirit. Right? 1 Corinthians 3, 1
Corinthians 6, it's all over the New
Testament. Peter tells us that we're
living stones being built into a holy
temple. Clearly, this language that
Isaiah is using, though it is couched in
Old Testament terminology, he's already
tipping his hand. He's telling you that
this stuff has been transformed by
virtue of referring to the fact that
Unix participate in it. Something that
was not true under Moses. Okay? This is
all indicative of the new thing that God
is going to do. The temple is not going
to be a part of this future new Exodus,
this future new worship. We already know
that. We've seen that over and over
again in the law in in the prophets in
the New Testament. He says here that
they're going to serve in his walls and
they'll they'll get a name better than
sons and daughters. I'll give them an
everlasting name that won't be cut off.
Notice verse six. The foreigners who
join themselves to the Lord so the
Gentiles to minister to him to love the
name of the Lord and to be his servants.
Everyone who keeps the Sabbath and does
not profane it and holds fast my
covenant. These I will bring to my holy
mountain. But notice, remember, under
the New Covenant, there's no mountain
that's that's singled out. Okay? What
what I'm trying to get you to see is
you're not supposed to read this stuck
in the mold of the Old Testament. He's
using Old Testament language, but he's
already explained to you how to
understand this by all the stuff that
I've talked about. And even if that's
not clear to you, the prophets are the
infallible interpreters, Christ
spokesman. They've told us how to
interpret this, right? They've told us
that Christ and the church are the true
temple. They've told us that uh we are
to offer sacrifices, not literal outward
sacrifices such as were ordained under
the Mosaic law, but a spiritual service.
Right? These things have all been
transformed. But what I'm driving at is
so has the Sabbath. So has the Sabbath.
Notice I'll bring to my holy mountain.
But there is no mountain for the
Christian that we are to gather on.
Right? Jesus said,"Woman, I tell you a
truth, the truth that in the future,
right, or a day is coming and has now
come, now is neither on this mountain
nor that one will people worship." But
God is seeking people who will worship
in spirit and in truth. He's contrasting
old covenant forms with new covenant
realities. All the stuff that you're
hung up on regarding which location is
no longer going to be relevant. Okay,
this is what Isaiah is saying in his own
way, but Jesus has brought out more
clearly. He says, "These I will bring to
my holy mountain and make them joyful in
my house of prayer. Their burnt
offerings and their sacrifices will be
acceptable on my altar." Is there going
to be literal sacrifices? Now, those who
insist that Sabbath here is to be taken
literally have not paid attention to
Isaiah. They're not interpreting Isaiah
in light of what Isaiah's been saying,
and they're altogether ignoring Jesus
and the apostles. Okay? These things
have been transformed by virtue of the
coming of Christ and the greater work
that he has performed. Okay? If you want
to argue for the necessity of observing
Saturday, you have to do the same thing
with burnt offerings and sacrifices. You
have to say there's supposed to be a
temple now and an altar and on and on.
Okay? All of this, you've already been
given clues all the along the way in
Isaiah. Now, if we go to Isaiah 66,
we'll see this even more.
Um, that was very quick. Uh he says uh
thus says the Lord, heaven is my throne
and the earth is my foottool. What is
the house that you would build for me
and what is the place of my rest? Notice
this. This is new creation. Okay? It was
the temple that served as an earthly
type and shadow of this reality that God
uh you know dwells uh in heaven and all
of reality is is created as a temple in
which God dwells and and is intends to
dwell with his people. Here he's saying
the new creation envisions this. It's
it's not ultimately that there would be
this one plot of ground in which God is
dwelling and everybody has to go to it.
God is saying that his desire is for uh
his presence to be known by all people
in in reality as a whole, right? Um
awkwardly putting this, but the in other
words, it's not in one place that God
intends for his name to be known and for
people to worship him. It's the whole
creation is to be uh his dwelling place.
Not just in the sense that he's
omnipresent, but in the sense that he's
known, right? He's he's worshiped. He
says in verse two, "All these things my
hand has made, and so all these things
came to be, declares the Lord. But this
is the one to whom I will look. He who
is humble and contrite in spirit and
trembles at my word. He who slaughters
an ox is like one who kills a man."
Notice the the sacrifices in 56. He
talks about bringing sacrifices
in the new covenant. That's the whole
section is about the new covenant. Here
he says that he who slaughters an ox is
like a man who who is like somebody who
kills a man. What is he saying? But that
they won't literally sacrifice.
Right? And so what what I'm driving at,
if people think that the the language
there that's used for the Sabbath
intends to convey that we're to
perpetually observe the Sabbath, they
don't understand the logic of the new
covenant. They might as well be
sacrificing animals. They might as well
be killing a man according to God
himself. Right? Paul says this is part
of the elementary principles. It's it's
likened to paganism. It's likened to
those who are in slavery now that we're
now that Christ has come. The the new
covenant, the new creation that we
participate in already doesn't intend
for us to observe these things in their
outward form. We're not supposed to
sacrifice. We don't have a literal
earthly altar. We don't go to a literal
temple. All of these things have been
done away with. Christ is the substance.
Christ is the reality. He is our rest.
Right? So, and and you could go on on
your own. Others can read this. I mean,
that's the whole point of these
chapters. It's not, as sabotarians
argue, intended to show that Saturday
continues into the new covenant any more
than temple, priesthood, sacrifice, or
altar or whatever are intended to
continue into the new covenant.
And all that's just introductory, by the
way.
That's a lot.
And that's good stuff. Um, I'm glad that
you covered that because Seventh
Adventists in particular love this
chapter of Isaiah. um and basically make
that exact argument that you were just
saying. So, um that's good stuff, man.
Do you have anything else?
Well, that was intro, but I mean I I
don't have any more intro.
No, no. I just wanted to make sure you
got everything out and you were able to
say everything um that you had prepared
for the evening.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'm I'm open to
questions. I'm open to any dialogue you
want to have. I know it's been three
hours. Maybe they're tired.
Yeah. I'm I'm I'm fine with whatever. If
if people have a couple questions, they
can maybe ask some questions. I know
there's a slight delay with the live
chat and our um our stream. We got to
pretty much all of the other questions.
I know they kind of kept going back and
forth about what you were or Exodus
16:29
um and people saying that that had to do
with um
collecting mana contextually.
Yeah. Yeah. I I kind of ignored that
because I I think it's evident. It
should be evident to people if Jesus is
doing it. Okay. If a sabotarian wants to
argue that you're supposed to literally
stay in your dwelling place on the
Sabbath, then they have to account for
why Jesus wasn't doing that because he
wasn't, right? Do they think he was a
lawb breakaker? You know, what are they
going to do with that? I I don't think
anybody from any position can really
maintain that, right? You got a problem
no matter who you are if you're going to
say that. So, I I think that's a clear
indication to people who are taking it
that way that they're misinterpreting
that.
If your interpretation makes Jesus a
lawb breaker, then your interpretation
is flawed.
You know, it's interesting, too. You
talked about Colossians 2. Um, that's
another verse that they love. And they
love the phrase, they love specifically
to use the King James where it says the
handwriting of ordinances.
And they like to try and say, see, this
is talking about the ceremonial law
being nailed to the cross. And so
therefore, it only nailed festival
Sabbaths. the ceremonial Sabbath. It
didn't it didn't abolish the weekly
Sabbath being the seventh day.
Yeah. Part part of the problem is and
that's what I was trying to address and
and this is something where you know you
can get into this more deeply. That's
why I say this is introductory but
the day that God chose is known as a
positive command. Okay. So there's you
you've probably read the Westminster
confession and where it talks about by a
positive law. So there's a difference
between ceremonial laws, positive laws,
moral laws. A lot of people aren't very
careful when they read, and I know some
people b at this. They don't like when
you make these distinctions. Civil law,
ceremonial law, moral law,
the three-fold.
Yeah. But but I I think it should be
obvious that let me give you an example.
There there are certain laws that are
given that are not intended to be
perpetual or universal. For example,
when when God told Abraham, "Take your
son, your only son, Isaac, whom you
love, right, and offer him as a
sacrifice." That was a positive command.
Meaning, God is commanding this of
Abraham alone. That anybody who reads
that and thinks they're supposed to go
offer their son is a buffoon, right? I
hope I can speak that uh casually
because it would be the the height of
evil for them to do that without warrant
from God. But but thinking they have it
from Genesis 22, right? That's a
positive law. There's there's nothing in
the nature of the case that
Abraham see like the law, thou shalt not
murder. That's a moral law. That's
something that people should know even
apart from Mosaic legislation, right?
It's a it's a law that's written on our
very constitution as image bearsers. We
know it's wrong, right? even if we
violate it by hating people and doing
things that tend to their destruction,
right? We know that by as as as image
bearsers, it reflects God's character.
But something like take your son and
offer him as a sacrifice isn't something
that Abraham would have known by nature,
right? He he could have only known it
because God said, and it's the same sort
of thing like the the law not to eat of
the forbidden fruit, right? The the the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
God said, "Don't eat." There there's
nothing in the nature of the tree that
made it wrong to eat it. It was merely
because God issued a positive command
saying not to do it. So, one way for to
help people get a handle on this is to
think of rules that you might give to
your kids. If if I tell my kids as
they're growing up, they're not supposed
to lie. And then I also tell my kids
they have to be in by 9:00, you know,
before the before it gets dark. I hope
that as my kids get older, when they
realize they can stay out after 9, they
don't also think, "Oh, well then I can
also lie, right?" Because yeah,
the one law is no longer binding. But
the one is a positive command. That's me
as a parent saying this is imposed on
you for some spec specific reason. I
have a reason for it, for your safety,
uh because I want you to get rest,
whatever it might be. Right? That's a
positive command. So here's the question
is I I would say that the requirement to
worship God is a perpetual moral norm.
We have the obligation to give to God a
due portion of our time just like we are
to honor him with our our our substance
what we get. That's a perpetual thing.
That's just in the nature of the case.
That's what's appropriate. We should be
offering things to God. Everything we
have comes from him. We're acknowledging
by our giving that he is the source of
all we have. And the same thing goes
with worship. There's as image bearers,
we should be setting aside time to
worship him, right? the idea that all of
our time should be given it's it's
amazing to me that any time should be
given to our own desires. Right? But but
here's the question. Is the particular
day on which we do so built into the
very nature of things such that it had
to be the seventh day and couldn't be
another day? Is that a positive command
the day or a moral command? I think it's
obvious that it's positive because it
wasn't in in itself holy. God blessed
the Sabbath day and made it holy.
Yeah.
God set it apart. Sorry if I sound like
I'm yelling, but uh I'm just animated.
But God blessed the Sabbath day. He made
it holy. He set that day apart. It
served a particular purpose in his
economy. Just like God rendered the
temple holy, the the cudman of the
temple holy, he set that apart for his
holy service. It doesn't necessarily
mean that all of this was intended to
serve this function in perpetuity.
Right? We know the temple which was holy
was not intended to be forever. The
priesthood was holy. It wasn't intended
to be forever. The sacrifices,
circumcision, all of those weren't
intended to be forever. And I'm
suggesting that the same sort of thing
holds true with respect to the
particular day. God could change the day
just like it was God's deliberate
decision to make that the day prior to
the coming of Christ. So yeah, the
Adventists make the day a moral thing
because they'll try to say the Sabbath
was being observed because they have
this pre-earth origin story um kind of
like Mormonism and it the Sabbath was
being observed there on the seventh day.
So even in heaven, they're following
this pattern. And so it wasn't um
something distinct to the creation here.
Um, and that's another one of the issues
because if they like to point and say
the the law is a reflection of God's
character, which we would agree. Um, but
then they want to tie the specific day
into that, making that some sort of
perpetually transcendent sort of thing
when in reality days are not like an
eternal
thing. So, they're they're I often say
they're infusing some sort of divine
characteristic, if you will, to a
rotation around the sun. Um, and I think
that that's rather ironic considering
that that movement claims we're
worshiping the sun by going to church on
on Sunday. Yet,
they're injecting a divine
characteristic into a day that has to do
with the sun.
So, it's bit of a bit of an irony there.
if I heard you correctly, you're you're
saying that some of this is rooted for
them in a pre-temporal or anti-mundane,
you know, uh, existence and things like
that. Now, part of the problem I'd have,
well, first of all, I'd argue against
any of them trying to to justify that.
Uh, there's no good biblical grounds for
anything like that. But secondly, the
text of Genesis itself is clear that God
sanctified that is set apart that day.
It wasn't in itself
holy.
Just like the temple mount was not holy
in itself. It was set apart for that
purpose. And so if God chooses to do
that with a new day, he can do that,
right? Just like he chose, you know, to
set aside these other things that were
holy. So they're going to have to deal
with the text of Genesis, which is funny
because I know that LG White, I'm not
the expert you are on at Adventism, but
I do know because I've I've read a
little bit of LG White and other
Adventist literature way back. I used to
have some interactions with Adventists,
but I remember it was funny that I would
sometimes hear them trying to argue for
certain things and I thought, "Hey, you
guys are lifting that out of the
Puritans, which is a tradition that I've
drunk deeply from, but you're you're
twisting and distorting it." And but uh
normally they'll say they want to point
to Genesis 2 in order to say that the
Sabbath didn't originate at the Exodus.
And so it's it's not something that was
uh displaced by the new covenant. I
think that's part of the argument that
they're trying to make. The problem is
because it started in heaven and Lucifer
was attacking it.
But but even so a lot of them what I
used to hear didn't go back that far. I
always used to hear them make this point
that it was a a uh creation ordinance.
And I would agree that this is a create
this is a thing that that is in place at
creation. It doesn't first come on the
scene at the Exodus, but this isn't
necessarily helpful because of the point
that I'm making that it was a positive
command that could expire when God
determines it to do so. Such as making a
new creation, right? Again, the whole
point of it is this was the day that he
chose because it was on that day he
rested from his creative labors. If God
does a new creation, wouldn't it follow
that he could sanctify the the day
that's appropriate to to when he entered
in his rest on I mean that's the whole
logic of of uh the New Testament on this
and so many other matters. But anyways
uh yeah so I'm just saying that uh when
to the extent that they try to use this
they they they flounder on the fact that
it's God who sets it apart. It's not of
in the nature of things that that day is
is a day of worship or or of rest,
however people want to call it. The
other thing
which means it can change. That's the
key point of bringing that up is that
it's it's it can that can change because
that's not the actual substance.
Yeah. And the other thing I would point
out is even even demonstrating that
something is preosaic
doesn't get away from the problem of
saying that the new covenant has done
away with the old. Because remember,
uh, well, I mean, the argument is, as I
understand it, you can correct me or
tighten it up if you want, but as I
understand it, is they want to say,
"Yeah, the new covenant does away with
the Mosaic, but the Sabbath precedes the
Mosaic covenant." Well, so does
circumcision. So does sacrifices, right?
All those precede it. They're caught up
into the Mosaic covenant because they're
all tied to everything that is pre-new
creation, right? uh sacrifices,
circumcision,
Sabbath observance, even if that all
precedes Moses, it's still typical. It's
still Yeah.
Uh anticipatory of new covenant reality.
So, it doesn't help them unless they
want to say circumcision is for today
because that precedes Moses, too. Or if
they want to say, you know, any of the
other things that the the patriarchs
did, right? They did a lot of things
that are, you know,
well, and the key to that is seeing like
you did tonight. I know folks that it
was a lot of information like you
mentioned, you know, might need to go
back and and listen again, but this is
the importance of seeing the biblical
narrative as a whole and seeing that
there is something bigger going on
behind these things. And like you showed
in Colossians 2, um the Sabbath did have
a typical aspect, something that was a
shadow that pointed to a greater
reality. We have a question here,
Anthony, um from Alpha Matter that asks,
can you expound more on the Greek word
that was used in Colossians 2:16,
Sabaton? Was this word strictly speaking
about the Sabbath? If so, Colossians
21:16 really means yearly, monthly, and
weekly?
Oh yeah, absolutely. I' I'd say that's
exactly what it's doing. If you look at
Leviticus 23, that that's what you have
there, right? You have um
festival, new moon, and the weekly
Sabbath. These are all called Sabbaths,
right? The term Sabbath is not exclusive
to the
last day of the week. And so when you
look at Leviticus 23 and it proceeds to
talk about various Sabbaths, the
festival
type Sabbaths, the new moons and uh
Sabbath day. I it's just following
Leviticus 23, right? You're familiar
with what I'm talking about there,
right? The
Yeah. Yeah. And it's talking about the
feast of first fruits. And um it
actually goes on in that chapter to talk
about holy convocations uh taking place
on the first and eighth day, which also
shows that um there are a lot oftentimes
they'll say, "No, God never called any
other day holy." Well, there you go.
Um Yeah. And it said holy convocations
were supposed to take place that day.
Yeah. And so notice notice convocation.
So, the person who was arguing before
saying that they literally couldn't
leave their houses and that, you know,
doesn't have a better explanation.
Notice there's convocations on these
Sabbaths.
Yeah.
Right. A Sabbath is considered um
it says in verse three, six days work
may be done, but on the seventh day
there's a Sabbath of complete rest, a
holy convocation. Right? The word
convocation is used repeatedly
throughout this section.
uh including its reference to
uh the weekly Sabbath. So no, you aren't
limited to your dwelling places on the
Sabbath day.
So are the 10 perpetual 21st century?
Paul asks because the SDAs I know
believe and say yes, we do. And I think
that is to um you previously discussing
the um the transcendence of the the ten
commandments.
Yeah. So one thing I'd say is just just
with respect to the word perpetual that
word is used I know how you're using it
and uh I'm just saying this as an aside.
The word perpetual is used in connection
with other things and it's the intent is
that
what's referred to as perpetual is
enduring as long as the this covenant is
is enduring. Right? So the boundaries of
the covenant are the boundaries of of
that perpetuity that's in view there.
When God creates a new creation or a new
heavens and a new earth which has been
inaugurated for Christians then then the
perpetuity originally spoken of is has
expired and again I mean that's in the
logic of the case when when God tells us
that sacrifices are to be done into
perpetuity that the temple is to be
forever that circumcision is to be
forever but then the old covenant itself
tells us there's going to be a new
covenant and no more sacrifices right
and then it begins to throw all these
other things into the shade and the
apostles come and say the same saying,
you know, that perpetual in that sense
means in terms of the the covenants
boundaries, right? It's not talking
about literal foreverness. Um, if I can
make up a word. Well,
uh, but now I know understand here when
you're saying the word perpetual, you
mean and I agree with you.
Well, you're asking a question, so I
don't know if uh you're making a
statement, but the the term
perpetual in another sense, I would say
has relevance to the ten commandments. I
do think the ten commandments are
reflective of the character of God, his
nature, which is unchanging. So when God
says, "Have no other gods besides me or
before me," it's because there are no
other gods. Not in the true sense of the
term. There there might be so-called
gods in heaven and on earth, but there's
no others that are gods by nature. As
Paul says in Galatians 4, there's only
one God by nature. And that's why God's
people are to have no other god besides
him. Okay, that's in the nature of the
case. That can't change. No covenant's
going to change that. There's only one
God. There will always only be one God.
We're only ever to have one God. Same
thing is true when it comes to idolatry.
It's never going to be okay to worship
God in an idolatrous way. It's never
going to be okay to take the Lord's name
in vain. It's never going to be okay not
to worship God. The fourth commandment
never going to be okay not to honor
father and mother. Never going to be
okay to take the life of a person. Right
on down through the commandments. Um
those are moral. But I did say that
there are things that are rooted in in
the in the commandments or that are that
are stated with these commandments in
their old covenant context that are not
intended to be perpetual in this
extended sense of forever. And I'll give
you an example. I'll give you an example
when when Paul when when the fifth
commandment, right? This is how I
remember the commandments. By the way,
if you're wondering how I remembered
that, it's because there's a I
remembered with my hands. I didn't show
you, but uh the fifth commandment is
honor your father and mother, right?
That's how I you know the sixth
commandment I always think of a gun
pointing at the other five. Thou shalt
not murder. The seventh commandment is a
hand saying stop before two people,
right? That thou shalt not commit
adultery. Anyways, there's there's
little hand signs for all those. But the
fifth commandment, honor your father and
your mother. the the decalogue says so
that it may go well with you in the
land,
right? In the land, right? But when Paul
states it now under the new covenant,
Paul extends it not only now to blessing
in the land, but he says so that it may
go well with you in the earth. Right?
Just like the author of Hebrews takes
certain old covenant promises to Abraham
and he expands them. He says, I mean,
Abraham wasn't he didn't have his sights
limited to the little plot of ground in
Israel.
That's not what Abraham was ultimately
looking forward to.
He's looking toward the heavenly Mount
Zion,
right? He's looking forward to something
far greater. That was just a type in a
shadow. It was a microcosm of what God
was planning. And so in the same way
with uh
um oh the in the same way what I'm
getting at is the the the the fifth
commandment in its old covenant context
is contextualized by that covenant. It's
stated as uh the stated blessing is uh
stated in terms of the old covenant and
blessing in the land. But now that the
new covenant has been established, the
moral command remains, but the blessing
now pertains to the entire world. Right?
It's it'll go well with you and the
entire earth. And so I'm saying
similarly, and I could do this with
other commands, by the way. Uh but the
fourth commandment,
it's no longer tied to a particular day.
And uh I mean Saturday, that's changed.
And uh it's it's uh there are other
things that are that are no longer part
of it, right? Uh there were there were
certain things that the Israelites were
required to do on Saturday. If people
are going to say that it's the command
is perpetual, why aren't all the duties
that were required on that day
perpetual?
Yeah. Those were ceremonial.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's that's here. I
perpetual. It says they're perpetual.
Everlasting covenant, right? Same
language. And the thing I think it's
important too in this topic um
specifically with regard to former
Adventists and you you hinted at this
earlier and I I chuckled because I point
this out all the time and a lot of
former Adventist current Adventists are
not familiar with this. The Adventist
pioneers were leeches. They borrowed
from other traditions and then twisted
them to make them fit with their own
thing. So oftentimes people will hear
these things like you've mentioned the
three-fold use of the law. A lot of
former Adventists are going to associate
that with Adventism. Wrong. That's not
unique to Adventism. They are taking
that and twisting it. So, they have
essentially a four-fold use of the law.
Um they they would agree with the the
three-fold use, but then they'll want to
tack on. But the law also reconciles.
It's part of the the the reconciliation
model.
And so, okay, that's then where the
poison pill is is slipped in where it
like breaks the law gospel distinction,
if you will. Um, and so I I just say
that to say what you're you're putting
down here in regards to his question,
um, I don't believe this gentleman's a
former Adventist, but if you are a
former Adventist, please understand that
that is not unique to the Seventh
Adventist Church. That is one of the um,
historical
uh, concepts that they latched on to um,
and then have twisted to make it their
own. And so don't think that that is a
distinctly Adventist concept.
So let let me read a passage real quick.
This is Exodus 31. Notice what it says.
It says, "The Lord spoke to Moses,
saying, "But as for you, speak to the
sons of Israel, saying, you shall surely
observe my Sabbaths, for this is a sign
between me and you throughout your
generation." So, this is among the
language that they think shows it's
something that's still binding. So, it's
a sign between me and you. I've heard
some Adventists say that those who don't
observe this are denying creation and
stuff like that, right? because this is
the day that God instituted as the the
sign of that, right? That he's the
creator and so forth. So, it's called a
sign between me and you throughout your
generation. So, that seems to indicate
that it's forever, right? Goes on to say
that you may know that I am the Lord who
sanctifies you. Therefore, you are to
observe the Sabbath, for it is holy to
you. Notice it's not just an idol day.
It's holy to you. Everyone who profains
it shall surely be put to death. For
whoever does any work on it, that person
shall be cut off from among his people.
For six days work may be done, but on
the seventh day there's a Sabbath of
complete rest, holy to the Lord. Not
just a day of rest, but a day that's
holy. Whoever does any work on the
Sabbath day shall surely be put to
death. So now notice this. So the sons
of Israel shall observe the Sabbath to
celebrate the Sabbath throughout their
generations as a perpetual covenant.
It is a sign between me and the sons of
Israel. For in six days the Lord made
heaven and earth, but on the seventh he
ceased from labor and was refreshed. So
there's all the language that I was
talking about throughout your
generations,
uh, forever,
uh, perpetual covenant, right? So three
of the the key terms that I often hear
them using, but watch how this same
language crops up over and over again in
scripture.
For example,
uh, this is Numbers 18. It says, 'The
Lord spoke to Aaron, now behold, I
myself have given you my charge, my
offerings, even all the holy gifts of
the sons of Israel. I have given them to
you as a portion and to your sons as a
perpetual
allotment. This shall be yours from the
most holy gifts reserved from the fire,
every offering of theirs. Goes on over
and over again, it refers to these
things as perpetual allotment. In verse
19 uh of Numbers 18, it says, "All the
offerings of the holy gifts which the
sons of Israel offer to the Lord, I have
given to you and your sons and your
daughters with you as a perpetual
allotment. It is an everlasting covenant
of salt before the Lord to you and your
descendants with you." Okay, here's
circumcision. A servant who is born in
your house, who is born who is brought
with your money shall surely be
circumcised. Thus shall my covenant be
in your flesh for an everlasting
covenant. Okay. All the language used
for circumcision is used for the temple,
for its rituals, for the priesthood. I
and I only quoted some of them.
Leviticus 24 has other examples.
Leviticus 16, 2 Chronicles 2. It refers
to the temple as forever. 1 Corinth or
First Kings 8 says, "I have surely built
you a lofty house, a place for your
dwelling forever." But what we know that
outward temple was not intended to be
forever. It was displaced by Christ, the
true temple.
That's good stuff, man. Um, we could
wrap it up now. I know that it has been
uh quite the the marathon here. I gave
you a forewarning, folks. Um, maybe
Anthony, when you do part two at some
point, maybe you can come do part two
again. Um, here because this was
excellent. Thank you again for coming
on. Let people know. His channel is
linked down in the description box down
below. If you are into stuff like this,
as well as um debates, uh scholarly type
stuff, church history, um from a
classically Protestant perspective,
check his channel out. Anthony, anything
else that you would like to share with
people before I give us a sign off?
Uh no, I think that's it.
Well, again, thank you for thank you for
being here. Hopefully, like I said, we
can do this again sometime. It was uh it
was great. So, thank you for that.
Talk to you next time.
God bless.
All right, folks. So, hopefully that was
beneficial. I know that it was a lot.
Again, if you need to go back and listen
to those things over again, please do so
because this is a topic that does
require um not everything in in
scripture is just sound bites, folks. Um
sometimes it requires going deeper on a
matter, looking at things from a more
broad perspective. If you've been
watching the stuff on the channel
consistently, we have talked about some
of these themes tonight. He brought up
that Ucius quote. We looked at that a
couple weeks ago as well. He went far
more in depth on that which was amazing.
Um, so I'm grateful for that. Hopefully
that was beneficial to you. Hopefully
you guys you learned some stuff um even
outside of just the Sabbath, but kind of
saw how the biblical narrative as a
whole is really connected at the hinge
to Jesus Christ. And that is what the
Sabbath is ultimately about. Um, and so
praise God for that. Next week, Sam
Frost is gonna be on the channel. We're
gonna be talking about Daniel and
Revelation. We're going to be talking
about somewhere I have it in here, I
think, uh his commentary on the book of
Daniel, but we're going to be talking
about some of the key verses for the
Seventh Day Adventist Church. And we're
going to get his opinions on that as
somebody who is uh well very qualified
to talk about specifically the book of
Daniel. So, that is one week from
tonight. Um, until next time. Thank you
so much those of you that hung out for
almost 3 and 1/2 hours. You guys are
champs. Uh, love you guys. Thank you for
being here as always. Until next time,
God bless.
[Music]